This is Jocko podcast number one 73 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Yeah,
sure.
Analyzed the wound.
Yeah.
Wallin was bleeding from his neck,
so he pulled out gauze and started examining the wound to assess the damage.
Wallins airway looked fine.
There was no vascular damage.
The medic could tell that the wound wasn't life threatening,
but the blood was still flowing.
You're going to be okay.
He said,
wrapping gauze on the wound.
He began exerting pressure to stop the bleeding.
Are you sure Wallen asked?
Yes.
I'm sure
the fire was nonstop.
Okay,
sure.
Didn't think it could get much worse until he heard a frantic call from Walton
on the radio bear.
Miralis and Ck K had been hit and they needed sure up there fast.
Did you hear that and asked?
Yeah,
I heard it.
Sure,
sure.
Said
his bleeding was minimal.
I'm good wall and said,
go get them.
Getting the Waltons team though posed a great risk.
Okay.
A medic is taught not to put himself in any unnecessary danger.
He has to stay alive so other soldiers can live.
But it had reached a point in the battle where he had to go so sure,
grabbed his bag
and headed into the fire.
And that is a passage from a book called no way out.
A story of valor in the mountains of Afghanistan by an author named Mitch Weiss.
And it tells the story
of the men of operational detachment Alpha three three three six.
It's a special forces ODA team going after a high value target in the shock
value in Afghanistan.
But when they got on the ground for this mission,
okay,
they were
okay
in a bad tactical position.
They were outnumbered,
they were outgunned,
but they did have one thing that could not be beaten and that was the will to
survive.
And the bonds of brotherhood that could not be broken.
And on top of those things,
there was incredible courage on display from all the men of the team above and
beyond the call of duty.
And one of those men.
Yeah,
the medic,
Ron sure fought not only against the enemy,
but fought to save the lives of his teammates.
And it is an absolute honor to have Ron here with us tonight to share some of
the lessons from that day in Afghanistan and
from the rest of the things that he's been through and live through on his
journey through life.
So Ron,
thanks for coming on man.
Thanks so much for having Mei.
Have honestly been a fan of the show for a long time and you know when you guys
offered
kind of weird to think about coming on,
but it's definitely a pleasure.
Well man,
it's great to meet you and uh,
you know,
we'll get to shark valley but you know,
let's,
let's figure it out a little bit about who you were,
where you came from,
how you grew up.
I know one interesting fact to start this thing off is that you are born on
December 7th Pearl Harbor Day.
He was born December 7th,
a obviously a few years later then in 1941.
But yeah,
I grew up with that and for some reason my parents always thought it was a good
idea to like get me news articles or,
or other reporting from Pearl Harbor and says like a six or seven year old,
hey,
read this.
I don't know why,
but yeah,
I'd always just,
you know,
was,
was it something that,
that we talked about as,
as part of my,
uh,
my birthday and happy birthday.
Let me tell you about Pearl Harbor side.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And in your group,
was your grandfather in your grandfather served?
My grandfather did serve,
he was in the navy,
so he was in the Pacific for several years.
He,
I'm trying to remember,
he was on the smaller aircraft carriers that they had on the Pacific.
Um,
you said he's on several of those aircraft mechanic and dodging kamikaze.
He's and for sure and other things.
I got a bunch of books on the Mq from World War II sailors and World War II.
It's,
those books are absolutely insane.
And what those guys lived through was horrific.
I look at that and maybe this is just me,
I don't know how you feel if given the option of being in an engine room on a,
on a destroyer in World War II,
hot sweating and by the way kamikaze,
he's like you said or two repeaters are going to slam into you at anytime and
there's nothing you can do about it versus storming the beach.
All stone,
the beach all day long.
Like that's me.
I Dunno.
Oh,
100% I would rather,
you know in land warfare combat,
like if you're going to shoot me,
I got a chance to show you the back and maybe this will work out my way.
Maybe it works out your way,
but we throw water in and all those other pressures like no thanks pass.
Yeah,
I know I owe,
I owe it to those sailors to,
to cover some of those books in there.
Those are those books.
But you know,
with your,
with your grandfather,
I mean,
just to live through that.
I can't even imagine coming back from that what your normal life is like after
you've lived through World War II as a,
as a sailor in the Pacific theater.
Ugh,
man.
Crazy.
Yeah.
My,
my grandfather,
he served in the Pacific.
Um,
my great grandfather was in world war one shooting artillery at,
uh,
at the Germans.
Um,
so we had that family history and,
and uh,
we have some family history.
He goes back all the way to the civil war.
Uh,
it gets a little,
you know,
little more like cousin level and everything are there.
But yeah,
they,
we've been fighting wars for this country for a long time.
Both of your parents as well.
But both my parents were in the air force.
That's where they actually met,
was in the air force.
And
Yeah,
we've just had that family history of service.
That was,
so that was pretty normal.
AndW and where were they stationed?
What'd you spend most of your childhood?
Uh,
I think like most military,
you know who kids?
Um,
I mean I was born in Alaska but then moved to Illinois to run.
Remember any of either of those places?
First by sire member is a mountain home,
Idaho,
which is just like tiny little place about an hour south of Boise.
And then from there I kind of,
we'll call Washington state home cause I spent fourth grade on growing up in
Washington state.
Yeah.
My,
my dad end up retiring in,
I want to say 91 from the air force and then we just kind of stayed there
afterwards.
And the and you were the only child?
Yeah.
So that would means those,
those birthdays were especially heavy.
He was like pure celebrate.
I got four kids.
I know you've got two kids.
I've got four kids and you know,
you can have a birthday and you don't even,
am I a bad parent?
I Dunno.
Probably,
yeah,
probably.
Yeah.
Cause of birthday.
Oh,
you know,
are we doing anything for my birthday?
I don't know.
When's your birthday today?
Oh,
okay.
Anyways,
it's my life.
Blows it out for our kids' birthday.
She's,
she's great at that.
I just kind of go along for the ride and my wife does a much better job than I
do as well.
I'm the person that's looking at the whole situation saying,
what does this stuff hanging up for?
Oh,
what did I get him for his birthday?
Yeah.
Uh,
and then,
so going to school,
where were you playing sports?
What were you doing?
What was your Gig?
And in,
in school,
uh,
I played the usual sports growing up,
you know,
soccer,
baseball,
um,
what I really kind of gravitated,
gravitated towards as a,
as I kept growing up was your endurance sports.
So I started,
my dad was doing triathlons,
so I started doing that.
Oh,
your dad was doing triathlons.
So he did the,
he did many triathlons.
He did the Canadian iron man a couple of times.
And so it kind of grew up watching that.
So I started with the triathlons in high school and then pretty quickly switched
over to just cycling road road racing,
cycling.
And I don't know.
I think,
I think those,
you know,
four or five,
six hour days on a bike got me ready for,
uh,
yeah.
Military Training.
I just know he's coming in on a bike.
Right,
right.
I'll never raised a bike before.
I know
guys that race bike and it's just pain.
It's just how much pain can you take?
Right.
Basically you were long stretch of road and you just keep on riding
and,
and apparently you've gotten some kind of crash.
Oh,
several times.
Well,
I know that,
I know that there's a little disruption in your plans because you get done with
high school and you want to join the Marine Corps or you get done with college,
you want to join the Marine Corps.
Okay.
So,
yeah,
I went to Washington State University,
was getting ready to graduate in the spring of 2001 and so started talking to a
Marine Corps
officer,
recruiter.
Um,
what did that process,
how'd your mom and dad feel about that?
They were as this space,
the air force is one side of the spectrum.
Marine Corps on the other side of the spectrum.
At least,
at least I was gonna I was talking about the officer's side when I later said,
hey,
I'm joining the army enlisted.
Then they just,
they just lost it.
Then they're like,
what are you doing?
You just,
but um,
yeah,
so that was getting ready to graduate Washington state,
um,
start talking to the marine corps and went through the process.
We basically,
that was,
it was accepted through the Marine Corps program to go to ocs starting in
October of 2001.
That's awesome.
Um,
but the navy medical board had seen,
um,
well I thought it was a flag on my,
my medical records from being hit by a car in 1995.
And sorry,
I never spent a day in the hospital back then with pancreatitis,
which usually would be considered,
are related to drug abuse,
alcoholism,
just something serious,
or you have some serious medical condition.
And,
uh,
so because of that they told me no and I August of 2001 that now we're,
we're good.
We don't,
we don't need anybody.
Um,
so yeah,
Kinda,
yeah.
Got left out to dry there.
And then,
so then what was your plan?
Uh,
from there I started at graduate school.
and economic original degree in that was business economics.
Did you do,
were you getting that degree but you knew you wanted to go in the military?
I mean you,
you or did you get done with your degree in say,
oh no,
what am I going to do now?
Maybe I'll go in the marine corps a little bit of both.
Um,
so service was definitely always a part of our
family life growing up.
And so it's definitely in the back back of my mind like I need to give back,
do something for the country.
Never quite knew what.
And then
trying to go to ocs just seemed like something to do for a while and give back.
And then when that didn't work out,
I started a graduate school to
use that as kind of a reset time.
I figured out,
okay,
that's not working out.
Now what can I do?
And you know,
it was a few weeks into that,
that nine 11 happened and then we had to revisit,
revisit the decisions again.
And so then what did you do once a,
once a September 11th happened,
uh,
so I was in graduate school for Economics and um,
and I'm spending,
spending that first year,
uh,
continuing with education and just watching,
watching it on TV and just didn't feel right to sit there and watch it.
Um,
so try to figure out what,
what made sense at that point too to do.
And then for some reason,
enlisting in the army sounded like a good idea.
So,
so that,
uh,
summer of 2002 I went down an army recruiter and of course at that time they
were like,
sure,
we'll take your weekend.
We can scratch that
now.
Did you,
did you know you wanted to try for SF at that point?
Um,
they,
they talked to me about going in with a SF contract and it definitely sounded
interesting,
but I know part of me just didn't feel
like,
oh the,
I could be an SF guy.
Cause I mean I grow up just like everybody.
We were watching Rambo,
you're watching other things.
Like that's what a green baret is,
like certainly don't,
don't fit that mold.
Um,
but so they talked about that,
but I was like,
well,
let me get in,
let me get some experience in the military and then we'll go from there.
So I,
I signed up to be a medic who did basic training.
Uh,
oh,
I'm forgetting the name right now,
Fort Jackson,
South Carolina,
and then went off to Fort Sam Houston and then went to airborne school.
And along that way I got,
I ended up getting myself a ranger contract to try and go to the center for the
Rangers.
So at some point you,
you realized,
all right,
I'm going to step up and try and go to a little bit more special operations
side.
Something got in your head.
Yeah,
I'm got in my head.
Um,
and if I remember correctly,
I think it was orders to Korea.
I think that was my,
the,
the first thing that came through.
It was like a,
let me see what else I could do.
So I,
I talked to their recruiters,
got,
got the,
uh,
the ranger.
I don't know if it was a contract at that point,
but I got that set up.
So it might be different now,
but after,
after airborne school and any infantry guys or ray or medics or whoever's trying
to go to,
to the ranger,
you,
you'd go out the next day,
wait on the little lines out there at airborne school and they'd come by,
they look through your paperwork,
pick you up,
and then take you,
take you over.
So they come out,
they start flipping through everybody's stuff and they get to mine and they
start looking at my paperwork,
which is still the same paperwork from,
I'm trying to do the Marine Corps ocs thing.
And so it's of course a disaster.
It's,
you know,
not physically qualified,
but then there's like lines through that and waivers and arrows and just
nonsense.
Um,
but I look at that and they're like,
well,
you're not,
not physically qualified to be
here.
And so they just kind of drop my paperwork.
It took everybody else and left me,
left me standing there.
Um,
so now had to revisit a what to do again.
So I ended up spending a few weeks sitting there.
Everyone's goal just to kind of being,
you know,
a little,
whatever they needed done that sucked.
They'd,
they'd make me do a while.
I waited on new orders to go somewhere.
Um,
yeah,
we did.
I did that for a little while and I finally got orders,
uh,
up to Fort Bragg to go to the 44th medical command.
Um,
and so while I was packing up all my stuff,
head up to Fort Bragg and fortunately,
uh,
my,
my medical records got lost along the way.
Did you say?
Fortunately,
and unfortunately I'm a specialist in the army,
you know,
I don't want to lose stuff and show up,
but it,
it got lost along the way.
So,
uh,
medical paperwork read,
done,
none of that.
Wow.
Uh,
none of those waivers or anything.
Got All that situated,
um,
reported to my unit on,
I think it was a Thursday,
some Thursday and in August had been 2003 at that point.
Uh,
well that's because those,
those army,
the medic schools are a long time basically.
So that at this point you'd been through bootcamp,
Army boot camp and then you went to are to be a medic.
How long is the training to be a,
like an infantry medic?
Uh,
the men of course was four months.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I did basic,
I did the,
the medic school and then you had an airborne school and then that interim time
while they try and figure out something to do with me.
And so I showed up to my,
my unit went after you in process in August of 2003.
Um,
you know that first day we do PT.
Then the first sergeant calls me,
I'm like,
Hey,
what do you want to do with your,
your life plan on putting in an SF packet and try this,
try something else again.
And,
and again,
the thing that's drug,
what's driving you to do that?
Like,
did you see some SF guys?
Did you talk to some SF guys?
Did you watch Rambo again?
What was the persuading of accurate?
I don't know.
I think it was
mixture of a lot of different emotions.
And
I'd had enough
validate my feelings because I was just some specialist in the army.
But I was like,
I think I'm pretty good at this stuff,
so let me,
let me try and push myself a little bit harder and try and find something else
to do.
So I,
I put in for SF,
there's a guy named Travis mills.
He rehearsed Travis Mills.
He's an awesome guy,
but he,
we,
he was on the podcast and,
and he's a,
he's a quadruple amputee amputee and he's like the,
uh,
got the damn spirit of a,
of a freaking,
like the ultimate human being warrior.
But anyways,
when he was growing up,
he played varsity football and basketball,
whatever.
He played every sport.
He broke all these records.
He was this big strapping guy,
taught like a total stud,
just,
just a total stud.
And you know,
I asked him,
I said,
well,
you know,
how come you didn't try for Rangers?
Somebody said,
he's like,
I do or why don't you try for special forces?
He's like,
I didn't,
I didn't think I could make it.
And there's like this thing where like for me,
I,
I'm,
I'm one eighth of the athlete and the physical specimen that Travis mills is,
but I was just dumber,
which is dumb enough to say,
oh I think I can make it through this training,
bring it on.
You know,
he was too smart to to say,
you know,
he was too smart thing.
She was too humble,
really too humble.
Cause I had some level of arrogance.
I mean I think there's a difference between,
cause that happens on a fairly regular basis,
you know,
special operations and special forces has this kind of mythical buildup where
people start to think,
well I dunno if I can actually make it through that.
It's gotta be so hard.
Whereas I'm always looking at people like,
oh,
you were a wrestler,
or Oh,
you played football,
varsity football and your high school,
or you,
you swam on the swim team or whatever,
you'll be fine.
Like you can do it.
But people build it up to that mythical level that you don't think you can make
it.
So I,
the reason I was asking that,
cause it's,
it sounds like you made a transition from,
I don't know if I can do that.
And then once you're there and you're looking around,
you're going,
you don't want to take,
I can actually do that.
You got,
you either got dumber
or you just got more,
you know,
little,
and that's what I think it is.
I think it is,
you know,
you see,
you see yourself in comparison with everyone else's there and you go,
okay,
cool.
I'm,
I'm hanging with these guys.
I can probably make this happen.
So no,
that's cool.
That's cool.
Um,
yeah.
And so,
so now we're talking,
uh,
that fall
2003.
So Afghanistan's role in Iraq is,
is going,
uh,
at that time that the unit I was in the,
it was a medical sport company.
They weren't even supposed to deploy.
I think the calendar had them going in like 2005.
So like you're like that's a lifetime away.
I came all the way here to not go anywhere.
So I put in for selection,
we got uh,
we got,
got those medical records redone.
So I go,
um,
so I went in January of 2004 to selection and now we can always talk about that
more.
But when I came back then my unit is all in desert camouflage uniforms and link.
You guys,
you guys go on somewhere and they're like,
why have things changed in those three weeks?
You were gone for going and I'm like four weeks.
Oh,
so,
so you went to special Ed.
So they send you,
they send you like ta di to special forces selection.
Is that what happens?
Like temporary,
they don't transfer you there permanently.
They just send you for a correct for the,
for the three weeks selection process,
you just get temp orders over,
you do your thing.
If you get selected,
then you wait for orders to go full time to the Q course.
And then that initial selection is just like a beat down.
Yeah,
three weeks.
Um,
you know,
probably not a different than most selections for different soft units around
the world.
It'll don't walk in the woods with heavy bags.
Get lost,
then we're going to make you carry heavy stuff.
And I remember logs,
a lot of logs.
Then he did carry it.
Apparently they didn't belong over here.
They belonged over there.
How'd you do in that?
Did you feel all right?
Uh,
I mean honestly,
uh,
I didn't know what I was getting myself into,
so I obviously passed.
I got selected,
but I didn't feel like I was where I wanted to be for that process.
Um,
it definitely beat me up more than I thought it should and it,
it helped reset me.
So I spent the next couple of months when I was getting ready for those orders.
Really resetting the way I was training was getting,
getting myself mentally prepared for it.
And so once I got to the phase two of the course,
I thought that was how you were a little older cause you did college and this
was 2004 so I was at that point 25 was that older for maybe 26 it was going
through a non for no,
not for special forces.
I was definitely one of the oldest guys at basic training when I was going
through.
But for,
for special forces,
it tends to be those older guys who've been in the army for a little while of
I've seen stuff,
got some experience,
then decided they wanted to explore some different routes.
So you come back from the initial selection course in all your guys are in
desert Gamey and they're getting rich.
So did they end up deploying quickly?
They deployed a couple of weeks later the to deploy to Iraq or Afghanistan.
They went to Iraq.
Did they?
Did they,
did they run the cash in Baghdad?
Some of them were east doing,
I want to say they were doing prisoner.
Hmm.
Uh,
you know,
DTT support patients or whatever,
some of the prisons.
Um,
but luckily my company commander pulled me in in the other office and basically
said,
yeah,
you're on these orders
but if you want to,
if you want to go pursue something else,
I see some value in that.
So if you want to go,
you can go and see your company commander took care of you and said you can go
to the Q course.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
You know what's cool about that is that God just leaves a good impression on you
about the army.
You know what I mean?
I was thinking that when I was a young enlisted guy and somebody could either,
you know,
maybe screw you over is a hard term,
but you know,
some could either like look out for you or just kind of let the big green
machine do its thing and when someone actually looks out for you,
just give you such a much better appreciation and connection to,
you know,
like I had guys that looked out for me when I was a new guy and I always that
that just heightens your commitment to the team.
You know,
that there's people like that.
Whereas the people that try and you know,
oh you're just going to do this anyways needs of the navy.
That's what they say.
The in the,
in the navy they say needs of the navy.
Those are the needs of the navy so well,
and you're going to get some.
And so after my company deployed,
basically are,
our battalion had four companies to deployed to stayed behind.
So we kind of fell under the two that had stayed behind.
And there was some people over there who had that attitude of you think you're
better than us?
I like,
I,
I don't,
I'm just trying something different.
And so they made life interesting for a little while,
but we got through it and,
and then so what did you train?
What did you change differently about your training?
Where you learn from selection?
Like,
okay,
I need to work on humping a Rockmore or whatever.
What was the,
what were the big things that you learned you needed to work on a more weight
and moving faster?
I mean,
not too,
um,
it's,
it's pretty simple really,
man.
I'm not a big guy.
I'm five,
six at the time I went to selection,
I think it was about 135 pounds.
So you,
you put on that way and it's,
it's a lot.
So I put on some more weight.
I just got a little more used to,
to move in with that.
And because you've got to carry,
it doesn't matter if you weigh 220 pounds or 120 pounds,
you've got to carry the same weight.
Right?
Yeah.
Had the packing list is what it is.
The minimum wait for the day is what it is.
It doesn't matter if you're six foot three or four or five foot six,
you're just going to go get some.
And then how was the Q course?
Qrs and Silva.
I thought it was really,
really good course.
I thought it,
I thought he did a great job getting you ready for things.
I had no experience in a,
so it's all,
it's all changed around a little bit since then.
But so for me,
when I showed up,
you got a three of a small unit tactics portion.
Basically learn how to
be an infantryman,
which from from being a medic,
I mean I had the basic training experience,
but I didn't know anything really about that.
So he spent about a month and a half and should learning how to move with,
with a,
a small unit,
you know,
just the basic military drills,
break contact,
initiate an bushes,
those things.
And then from there we started the medical course,
which for SF medics is a,
is a year.
Um,
basically just learning every single thing they could teach us in a year.
You know,
of course trauma,
medicine,
heavily enforced.
And then,
you know,
just all the weird and random diseases you might see around the world.
Did I,
I actually met my future wife during the medic course.
Um,
and so when I go see her on the weekends I'd pull out,
you know,
medical manuals and be like,
all right,
start,
you know,
start grilling me on these things.
And so she pretend she had whatever random disease you could get in data from
around the world.
It was,
it was pretty fun.
Date nights he had over,
I dunno why she and she put up with it,
but she did.
And
so where were you when you were were,
where's that chunk of the course take place?
Is that,
that's 18 delta,
right?
Yeah.
Rolling through the 18 delta?
No,
of course.
All the ESF core,
the Q chorus was a hall I'll based at Fort Bragg,
so I was already at Fort Bragg,
so really I just had to move across post when I started.
And then
are they,
when you're going through 18 delta,
are they still,
are you still doing tactical physical evolutions or is it like really starting
to get focused on classroom really focused on the,
the,
the medical aspect of stuff.
There's
a lot of classroom stuff cause they got a lot of,
yeah you got to teach you.
But they do,
they also do a great job of pulling out in the woods and um,
can't remember all the different segments of the chorus.
We have a combat trauma lanes.
You have just so many different portions where you get used to,
you know,
training people out in,
out in the dirt.
And I remember,
I'm sorry,
I think I started that course in
August,
September of 2004 and so we were rolling through the winter and I still
distinctly remember being out in the woods in January when it's like 15 degrees
and you're the patient and you know,
like somebody there,
somebody is working on you,
you know,
to practice and you're like,
please do it faster.
So I can,
I can get out of this because you know,
you,
how do you treat a patient who has wounded,
you have to expose removers,
roads.
So they'd be going through stuff and they'd be like,
you know,
do you feel this or do you feel that?
And like the patient saying yes,
but no,
I don't feel that cause my,
my feet are frozen right now.
Um,
but so it was,
it was a great course.
Um,
we did
two one month blocks where you go out to hospitals around the country and work
in the ers or work with,
uh,
anywhere in the hospital,
ob,
just different aspects.
Uh,
go to the local fire houses right on the ambulances,
get those experiences.
So yeah,
the,
the medical training that the UN and the seals used to go to 18 delta are
sealed.
Corpsman used to go to 18 delta.
Yeah.
They don't want any more.
Now they have a separate course.
Okay.
But the training that they got and the training of that,
the course provided,
it's just awesome training.
I mean,
it's a legendary,
awesome training.
And who knows how many lives have been saved because guys went through that,
that block of training and we're just so good and at doing all this stuff under
a Poncho at night stop and bleeding,
working on,
you know,
healing people with all kinds of,
in inclement weather,
in the dirt,
like you said,
all that stuff.
There's the,
the training that they prepped our medical guys four was phenomenal.
Yeah,
I was super impressed having been a medic before and then kind of stepping
it up a level like that.
It was,
he was really,
really nice to see where we're going to take a year or we're going to really
take our time,
teach you everything you need to know from the ground up.
Um,
yeah.
And just to continue to build those basics,
you know,
from starting early on with,
classes,
sticks and rags.
Like,
okay,
everything else is going to be great.
We're going to teach you that stuff.
But you know,
sometimes this is literally just a stick in a rag.
You can stop a lot of stuff.
You can save a lot of people along as you've had that experience and then of
course moving on later to usually he must attic agents,
you know,
to like quick clot or something like that.
It really stopped by like,
okay,
this is easy now because I had to stop at last week with literally go find a
stick and cut up some clothes,
tee shirt.
Now you're giving
me actual materials like,
okay,
I got this.
Going back to the Q course,
the initial kickoff of the Q course,
was there anything that you had major issues with?
What do you mean?
Like when you were going through,
not selection,
but through the Q course,
was there anything that you would like,
I'm not going to make it through this.
I'm going to fail this.
I'm not good enough at this.
Like for me,
I wasn't really good at anything.
I was like everything that I did because basically every week going through seal
training,
you get tested on,
you get a timed run,
you get a time to swim,
you get a time to obstacle course and then there's usually some kind of a water
evolution that they're going to test you on,
whether it's underwater,
not tying are lifesaving or breath hold or whatever.
They've got these evolutions wearing,
they're stacked up.
And that's one of the biggest pressures that that I felt going through was for
me like to,
to pass a form l timed run,
which the,
when I went through the,
the runs were not for miles.
They were however long they happened to be that day.
They might be 3.8 they might be 4.6 no one knew soft sand,
high tide.
And
I failed one run,
uh,
because I decided I was going to pace myself and that was not smart.
And after that one run,
then I failed.
I just had to go as hard as I could for the whole time.
I had set a sprint as hard as I could and then I pass and it was kind of the
same thing for everything.
Like I just had to go hard,
but you know,
I was worried that,
oh,
I might fail another swim.
I might fail.
Was there anything where you were thinking to yourself,
man,
if I don't,
if I don't pay attention,
I might not make it through this training.
Uh,
I'll say any of the,
any of the time we were out in the woods doing infantry stuff cause I just,
I didn't have that experience.
I worked my butt off trying to learn,
trying to pick up,
follow the guy's like,
oh yeah,
that guy is been a ranger school.
He,
he's done this,
he's done.
He started done a combat deployment.
Let me,
yeah,
let me hang out a little closer to that guy and see,
see what he does when we're setting up a patrol base,
those kinds of things.
Um,
but honestly I think like a lot,
a lot of people,
I have that two sides of the coin on me.
Like I have that little bit of dumb arrogance.
Like I the,
I can do this,
but then I also have that I don't belong anywhere near these guys.
Like these guys are,
you know,
they've been,
they're actually done that.
I what have I done?
Um,
so I,
I was always trying to find that balance internally of yeah,
I can do this or,
or,
or no I can't.
I guess that's a big difference between when you go through seal training.
Pretty much everyone's going through training is not been done,
not done anything before.
So even,
cause if you might've been the regular navy,
but even most guys haven't even been the regular navy,
most guys are just co you go through boot camp,
you go through prep course and then you go show up at Bud's and that's it.
That's,
that's what you do.
So there's no,
you're not looking at anyone going on how this,
this guy has done
stuff before or anything like that.
And also you're not doing anything in,
in basic seal training.
You're just,
there's no tactical,
there's barely any tactical knowledge being taught at all.
It's like carry this boat on your head for a long time.
And it's going to hurt a lot.
And then when it hurts a lot,
keep going.
Right.
I mean,
SF definitely has that aspect too.
Like you've,
if we find the right people,
we can train you at any point on what we want you to do,
but we just got to make sure,
you know,
you're not gonna,
you're not gonna quit on us.
And
I don't know.
I think just along the way,
I was just,
I was too stubborn to quit.
Definitely.
I definitely wanted to all the time,
but you know,
it wasn't gonna give him the satisfaction
and the,
so,
so then you get done with that.
You get done with the Q course,
you get done with 18 delta,
and then when do you get,
when did they give you your green baret?
So,
uh,
for us,
um,
I ended up finishing the entire Q course in May of 2006.
Um,
so I'd done selection in January,
2004,
had a couple of months break while I waited on orders,
started the Q course proper in June of 2004 and then may of 2006 when I,
I graduated.
Dang,
that's a long pipeline isn't it?
It's a long pipeline and that's
zero recycles.
That's zero.
Getting injured.
That's just,
that's just what it is.
Um,
all the other jobs are,
they teach you the job at about three months,
whereas the medic,
they teach it and 12,
12 months,
so everybody else can be that much shorter than,
than our pipeline.
Uh,
but so it was about May,
uh,
that's when I got the bring Brad graduated to the Q course,
got my orders over to a third group.
Did you,
were you married?
Did you get married yet?
So,
uh,
graduated the Q course in May of 2006.
Right?
Yeah.
And so I got that couple week break before reporting to my unit and my wife and
I got engaged.
And then,
so I reported over to third group towards the end of June of 2006 and they say,
hey,
go over to third battalion,
they're going to get you slotted third battalion's like,
Hey,
go to Charlie company.
And I show up to Charlie company three,
three and there's just,
there's nobody there.
Like,
like my,
the first guy here,
like what's going on?
And uh,
there,
there was one guy in there and he was like,
oh,
everybody's on block leave cause we were going to Afghanistan and a couple of
weeks.
So I went home,
told Miranda,
uh,
the situation.
And so we,
we need a quickie marriage but we didn't want to have to try and plan while I
was gone.
And then there's also those aspects of,
you know,
the military doesn't give a damn about some girlfriend or a fiance or anything.
And so we,
you know,
we decided,
she wants,
you know,
an actual wedding ring and actual dress,
these few things.
Can we get them done or we got it done.
So we got married and then I
these,
he didn't do a quick wedding but you got married in two weeks,
so it was like three weeks.
That's awesome.
It was,
you know,
it wasn't like a,
a Lope right away.
Uh,
cause we'd been together a year and a half at that point.
Um,
so yeah,
it wasn't quick,
but it was,
it was pretty quick.
It's awesome.
You know.
Did your,
did your family,
uh,
how'd you tell your family
that text message
at that point in texts?
Really where that they,
cause you had to type so many buttons,
you know,
just to send a message.
Um,
so we ended up bringing a,
her parents,
uh,
my parents.
Oh,
that's awesome.
They actually came down.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
we actually went,
where do you do a non quickie quick marriage?
Vegas.
So we all met up there.
Oh,
so cool.
So you did a Vegas wedding and we're still going.
I mean,
what this summer will be 13 years.
Uh,
so yes,
we got married.
Did you,
did you request permission from your uh,
sergeant to get married?
I did not.
I didn't even meet him.
I just wanted to let you out of the compound.
I just went on because nobody was there.
So they just
put me,
as soon as I showed up,
I went right back on leave,
Kinda got married and then it showed back up,
did some training and then met a bunch of guys for the first time and deployed
for seven months with them day.
And,
and what was that first appointment like?
Oh,
the first deployment
was
comparing my second appointment.
It was,
it was fairly tame that
half fall,
2,600,
2007 timeframe and Afghanistan we were,
we were working with the Afghans,
you know,
doing that stuff thing,
partner with them,
drain them,
take them out on missions.
Uh,
I don't,
I would just,
we just ended up and a Gardez Afghanistan and for some reason it was just hard
to find trouble then.
I mean obviously things ebb and flow in different areas and budgets.
At that time we really couldn't find too much work.
So were you guys,
you guys were training up these Afghan national police and to build
relationships with them.
And then you'd go out and do some kind of missions with them.
But the ACO that you were in was relatively tame at the time.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah,
we work with the,
the army and the,
and the police just training them up,
trying to get them ready to take over their country.
Cause that's the SF mission is to train you up so you can do the job and I can,
I can go home.
MMM.
Yeah.
Obviously all SF guys want to be the guy to go in and you know,
block the doors,
go in and clear it all yourselves.
But the ESAP mission is to,
you know,
get somebody else to go do it for themselves.
Yeah.
That's it.
For those of you that don't know,
that's like that,
that is the tenant of the bid.
That's the mission of the,
of the special forces of the Green Berets is to work with the whatever nation
you're in,
you build up their forces,
you help them,
you train them,
prepare them,
and then you advise them out on the battlefield and hopefully with your goal of
allowing them to eventually not need your advisement anymore.
And that's what,
that's what the primary mission of the special forces is.
And well,
in the seal teams we end up doing that as well.
You know,
we,
I don't know,
I'm trying to think of when we actually started getting tasked with that.
But you know,
we,
that's what we do now to,
you know,
we probably,
we lean towards,
you know,
direct action in special reconnaissance.
That's kind of where we live,
learn,
lean towards you guys,
lean more towards,
you know,
training up guerrilla forces,
but there's a lot of crossover and,
and all of us do everyone else's job to the best of our ability.
But did you,
did you feel like the deployment was like a,
what was your satisfaction,
was your personal satisfaction level of that deployment?
Uh,
I,
I think like most has half guys.
You've just gone through alone,
train up,
you've got all this experience,
you're,
you're raring to go.
And I had to pull him in.
I mean,
it was a good trip,
but it was,
it was a little quieter than I think most of the team would have liked.
Yeah.
If you're going to be gone and you're going to miss your family for seven
months,
so would you guys,
can we take them out to hit targets and they're just would be,
you'd capture your bad guy or yes or no,
but they born putting up resistance.
Yeah.
We,
we did villages.
We would go,
we cop plenty of bad guys.
Um,
just stayed at that point.
I don't know,
I think it was this kind of at a weird point in the war where d bye guys really,
they could quickly spot,
this is SF and they didn't really want too much to do with us,
so they just,
you know,
we'll pass today,
we'll find,
we'll find another unit to attack.
MMM.
But yeah,
it just,
yeah.
We caught,
we caught guys.
They just always been pretty good.
I'm pretty quickly,
I mean we,
we got in,
we'd get into a,
okay.
You know,
a couple.
Yeah,
just a couple of contacts over there,
but it was
okay.
Yeah.
Overall it was just kind of quiet area at that time.
Was it wintertime?
So we showed up there in August of 2006 and we stayed till march of two though,
I want to say march of 2007 so yeah,
it was,
is that winter or when you kind of have that low anyways?
Yeah.
Of the,
the winter time.
Yeah.
And like you said,
I mean things just go up and down cycles go up and down.
People,
the enemy gets agitated or they get beat down and they take a tactical breath
for a few months or whatever.
And then you come home from that deployment and you're,
so then what happens?
What's the life of an SF guy when you come home from that appointment,
you're going to start a workup to get ready to deploy again.
Yeah.
We already knew when we were going again.
Um,
basically the,
at the time there was three battalions ended up standing up a fourth battalion
and in the groups.
So kind of two battalions would be on the next rotation,
one would it be down.
And so it just happened that my battalion had to to uh,
back to back so to speak.
So we had seven on,
seven off and then seven on again.
So we knew right away as soon as we got back when we're going.
And then do you,
do you try and cram in a quick work up into that time period?
Of course.
So you know,
you got back,
so you got to first refit,
get everything re situated,
make sure,
uh,
you know,
all of this stuff.
He broke his is fixed.
Uh,
kinda began to take it a little bit at a time just to decompress.
And then we start the train up and you know,
we got,
got a few new guys in on the,
the team a got a new team sergeant and we got,
got a new team leader,
a couple of other new guys and you know,
just getting everybody ready,
get it on the same page.
Um,
honestly we,
the teams are,
we got Dennis got forward,
he was great coming from me.
Come from some training.
You come from some,
some different SF teams that had been over to Iraq and Afghanistan and had been
there,
you know,
early on in the war when it was,
it's a lot.
So he,
he put us through a lot of training,
got us,
got us much more prepared than we were prepared for the first draft.
But we were even better for the second one.
And Yeah,
we finished up that training.
Do a little bit more about the boys
like that when you had the,
the,
the new team sergeant coming in and he's all fired up to push you guys hard and
training was any push back from that.
Ah,
of course all of us are,
you know,
SF guys on a little bit like,
even though he's a teams are,
he's been around forever.
Yeah.
Like,
Oh,
who's this new guy coming in on the GM trying to tell us all what to do.
But you know,
it didn't take very long to see like,
okay,
he's got all this great experience and the training that he's putting us through
was,
it was definitely getting us hurt.
Getting us right eye.
Yeah.
And how much,
how much support do you guys get for training?
So do they do,
are you going organized training?
Are you guys running all the training yourself?
It's,
the company does coordinate some stuff,
but most of it's just have as heme level.
So,
you know,
the team started,
it's kind of that in coordination with the team later is kind of guiding the
team where they want him to be.
But then,
you know,
as SF is broken down,
you have your weapons sergeants who were,
you know,
supposed to be your weapons experts.
You have your engineers who,
you know,
handle the demolitions and,
and those things.
Your communications guys and your medics.
And so depending on the day,
it might be my day to teach,
so I'm going to get two days this week to just put everybody through many
medical course,
getting them,
get them ready just in case,
you know,
something happens,
I can't get there or something happens to me or something like that.
Um,
so everybody,
everybody is a subject matter expert and just kind of tries to tries to lift
that whole whole team up to be the best they can be.
There's no,
obviously each job is the best at their job,
but you want to know as much as you can about everything so that way
you know when things go wrong men.
And by that point it was kind of still theoretical to me,
but yeah,
when things went wrong.
Okay,
got you,
got,
you can handle this.
And then you guys already knew when you were growing deployment and you did you
know where you're going on deployment as well?
I don't remember when we found out what our next mission was.
I can't remember if it was early on or it was laying on.
I think it was fairly early on in our buildup,
um,
that we knew we were going to be working this time with the Afghan commandos,
which was a fairly new thing at the time.
It was right around that time that SF teams had just started,
hey Kate,
we're going to go through selection for the Afghan army,
were going to get the best we can.
We're going to train them up more,
start building these Afghan commandos battalions and they're gonna be the SF of
Afghanistan.
So I can remember exactly when,
but we knew we were going to be partnering with those guys
to do a little bit more of this trip.
So you,
so your expectation was that things were going to be a little bit hotter on the
second deployment?
Correct.
Did you believe that as a,
as like a one cruise wonder guy that don't,
don't one deployment or are you like things are going to be hotter or were you
just thinking,
Hey,
it's going to be the same as last time?
Uh,
I,
I think we all thought it was going to be a little bit more this trip just
because my first trip it was,
you kind of had a little bit more of a,
a region that your team was.
So it just depends on what your region is doing.
Got It.
Whereas this command us could go anywhere.
The commandos,
they were still fairly new so there wasn't that many.
So
over the course of the second,
my second deployment and we spent time at eastern Afghanistan,
we spent time down in Kandahar,
we spent time just going wherever they needed another battalion because like I
said,
there wasn't very many.
They were training him up,
but it takes a little while to get,
get guys trained up.
So you go on deployment,
you show up there and you started working with the commandos.
How was your relationship with the commandos?
How,
how,
how good were the commandos as you trained him?
Uh,
they were,
they were much better than Dan,
you know,
non selected force.
I think that's just
as to be expected.
Um,
you still gonna have those no variances in,
in your,
in your troops.
But we felt more comfortable.
So they were,
they were fairly capable crew.
They were better
understood.
And so you're out there working with these guys and what type,
what types of missions,
where are you doing?
Just basically going after high value targets?
Yeah,
yeah,
we would,
we'd get until,
uh,
on a high value target.
We,
you know,
trying to,
again,
going back to trying to train them to do the job for their country.
So we'd work with,
they're the team leader for the team would start working with the,
you know,
the,
the command level over there.
Okay,
this is the objective.
How would you take it?
And then they would kind of coordinate on a battle plan.
Um,
for me,
you know,
I'd make sure they're medics,
we're,
we're training up getting,
getting ready,
and then,
you know,
when it came time for an actual mission,
then each one of us would have a squad or,
or maybe a few extra,
which is,
how big is an Afghan commando squad?
I mean they were,
they're built around the same premise as a,
as a are an army,
you know,
light infantry unit.
So you'd have,
you know,
nine,
10 dudes,
um,
just depending on what kind of squad you had with you on any given day.
And so then you would be running your squad of Afghan commandos.
Once you're out in the field,
you would,
whatever the whatever,
just from a,
you're no longer just the medic,
you're now a little squad advisor for these Afghan commandos.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the medic piece is always there for,
for an 18 delta.
But,
you know,
best medicine is superior firepower.
So if we can,
if we can check,
if we can go,
hey,
we hit him overwhelming for us.
Everybody's good.
We,
when we talking about how tough we are and then we'd go home and,
and uh,
so yeah,
primary role is to advise that squad leader on mon how things going.
And then,
you know,
we also bring all the other assets that the US military comes with all that,
whether it's helicopter coverage or aircraft coverage.
So we can,
we're getting those,
you know,
that,
that extra intel that we can then push to these guys and be like,
Hey,
this is going on.
This is not going on.
Let's,
let's fix this.
Yeah,
no,
for me,
I think it,
I just wanted to kind of bring that out because it's,
it's pretty cool when you think about it.
You know,
you're,
uh,
you could be this young soldier and you're out there and all of a sudden you're
working,
you're,
you're an element leader.
Beat.
You go from just being a medic or just being the demo guy,
we're just being the communicator.
All of a sudden it's like,
Hey,
you know what?
Now you're doing that thing,
but you're also going to be advising,
which often times means you're actually leading this squad of commandos and
you're making sure that they're making the right moves.
So that's a very cool aspect of the job,
in my opinion.
You know?
Yeah.
It was
when you could see them getting better,
he was definitely a very rewarding,
and
he as he,
as you see them,
start to take more initiative and start to,
to,
you know,
be up front with you.
Like,
okay,
that's,
that's cool to see because I've been working with this guy for a while and I
remember one mission,
we were doing downing in Kandahar,
they,
we ended up getting infilled and we start looking at our,
our Georgi the grid reverence or they,
you know,
are a little map to see where we are and we're looking at it and it's 1:00 AM
2:00 AM whatever it is.
I'm like,
I have no idea where we are.
We're not on this map.
So,
um,
well we hear some gunfire and we're like,
let's go that way.
You know.
So,
so,
uh,
I have,
one of the interpreters with,
with me went by blade because they all want to knock you about their real names
in these situations,
but you know,
lay it and I'm like,
blade,
hey,
let's get this.
Let's get the trip.
Let's here moving towards gunfire and see what happens.
And then we start moving and we're doing our thing.
And at one point I looked back and blades right there on my shoulder,
he's doing his thing.
Yeah.
Like,
like where is everybody?
And they had hunkered down,
I kind of a couple of terrain features back and like,
well we got to go get him.
So,
but so you start there and then you know,
over time that gap shortens a little bit to uh,
you know,
ideally where they're leading.
Yeah.
What was the op tempo like?
How often would you guys go out and hit targets?
Um,
it would vary time time,
but with that,
that training and advising piece,
we were,
weren't going out like every night because like,
we got to take these guys from,
from ground up on mission planning and everything.
So we're going out several times a month,
two a
on bigger missions.
And then other little things as they came up
and when you,
so,
so it starts off,
these guys are not wanting to get anywhere.
They're not wanting to get shot at there.
If there's rounds fired,
they're hiding a couple terrain features away.
And then you're slowly progressing them,
building a relationship with them,
getting to know him,
the realize that they could actually do better.
And that process is going on in you arrived,
this was in 2007.
You guys are derived in October in 2007 is that right?
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
And then,
and then you're doing one,
two,
three missions,
getting these guys trying to push him each time,
uh,
to,
to do a little bit more,
to take on a little bit more responsibility.
And,
and this is just sort of the way it is.
Well,
and then what kind of training are you doing on top of that?
You're,
when you're back on base,
you're running them through immediate action drills,
you're teaching amount of shoot,
move and communicate.
That's basically what's going on.
Yeah.
Teaching those,
those basic infantry skills,
I'm taking them out to the range,
teaching him how to clear buildings,
teaching him,
you know,
just all the things you need to continue to reinforce.
And then like I said,
once you got a mission,
I go,
okay,
then we're gonna start going through those,
those,
uh,
tape drills.
And we're in build out a little village here as best we can with our,
our budget,
which was,
you know,
tape
and start building that stuff out.
So that way,
like,
okay,
we're going to it,
fill here,
expect to walk this way,
started,
you know,
going into those,
choreograph for hustles to get everybody,
get everybody ready.
So now as you guys got ready to go in the,
into the,
uh,
shock valley,
what was w did it seem like just another mission?
Did it seem like all this home,
it seems like it's going to be a little bit heavier.
What was your,
what was your assessment of it getting ready to do it?
Uh,
there were definitely a few
red flags that came with this mission,
but there's red flags with,
with,
with most missions,
like they give us a gun and,
and training for a reason.
Like they don't ask you to go to tickle file with somebody that
you're always expecting something.
Um,
but,
but uh,
you know,
it was just,
it was,
you know,
we'd gone after high value targets before.
Um,
we had intel,
he's over here.
We have Intel on what kind of,
what to expect.
So
you know,
was
our,
the plan that,
uh,
we end up going with.
Nobody was super excited about the idea of infilling at the bottom of a mountain
and then walk up that,
that does not sound fun,
but it comes to the point where,
you know,
this is the mission.
Yup.
All right,
cool.
We're going to do this mission the best we can and we're going to,
why did you guys have to answer it at the bottom of that hill?
Uh,
I think the decision was made that,
you know,
the Afghan commander was still being a little bit new.
Like they,
they knew how to fast rope.
Oh,
we had done that stuff,
but how many people do we want to risk in during,
on that,
and then just,
you know,
if there is resistance,
what,
what's gonna,
what's gonna come of that?
And,
and
I mean,
I try,
I try not to get too caught up in,
well maybe it would have been better if we'd,
we didn't fill that in on top.
Maybe would've caught an RPG to the 47
no,
you can't play then.
You can't play that game.
I've played that game with myself and it's not a good game to play now.
It doesn't mean that you don't look at it and you go,
Oh yeah,
okay,
here's what we saw.
This is why we made the decision.
This is something that you might brothers that are out there that could be in
the same situation where you gotta make that decision.
Considering how it worked out for me.
Right.
And,
and you know,
this is,
well a couple a couple weeks ago was an 11 year from that a battle.
But I was actually talking to some SF guys not too long ago when they were like,
we still talk about that mission.
We still talk about the,
the good,
which was the teamwork,
the,
you know,
the everybody coming together,
get this,
get this job done as best we could.
And we talk about the,
the less ideal parts as well.
And then make sure that we don't learn from somebody else's mistakes.
Don't,
don't repeat those.
And I think that's the great part about SF is you have that humbleness like,
hey,
we did not do this right.
Please learn we did this right.
Please learn.
And,
and yeah,
and,
and again,
the other side of that is like,
you could look at this thing all day and say,
well,
you should've gone and faster open on.
And like you said,
you take an RPG and do one of those helicopters and there's nine dead guys or
whatever and you go,
okay,
well I guess that wasn't a good plan.
So you can make the best,
you can make a horrible decision and it can work out well.
You can make the best decision.
You can work out horribly.
So whether that,
that's like a,
that's the way it is.
So what you do is try and learn from it and look at what you did and say,
okay,
well what could we have done better?
Could you tell from the the imagery and,
or the maps of the area,
what that terrain feature was like.
Cause I'll tell you what I was,
you know,
I was in,
in getting ready for this podcast,
I read a bunch about the operation and I kept reading steep terrain and you
know,
this,
that and the other thing.
And then,
and I kind of calculate it in my mind,
you know,
what that looked like in my mind and in my mind it was,
it was pretty bad.
It was like okay,
must've been pretty challenging.
Then I went and looked at actual footage cause there's a bunch of actual footage
because you guys a combat photographer and you had a bunch of overhead cover.
I saw that terrain rather,
I could not believe it.
I was,
I was saying,
oh my Mike,
like as bad as everything sounded,
it was 10 times worse when I saw that Terena I was like,
I can't believe that this,
that these guys did this.
Uh,
I agree.
Yeah.
And I don't just mean that from,
I can't believe you inserted there.
I was saying with the fact that you guys went up there that everything that you
had to do on that operation because the terrain was so steep,
I couldn't believe that you guys got out of there.
I mean it was just crazy.
Like,
you know what I mean?
You get used to,
you see the Predator imagery beforehand to kind of get a feel.
You've seen satellite imagery and get used to saying that stuff and you kind of,
you learn to build in that variance of this is what it looks like there,
but I know it's not going to be like that.
And so you Kinda,
you build in your right and your left limit.
It's like,
this is kind of what I think I'm going to see.
Yeah.
And it was still a little bit more than that,
at least for me.
Right.
What I was expecting.
Yeah.
It was no joke.
It's,
it's a borderline cliff.
I mean it is steep.
And anyone that's listening to this,
and you can go on youtube and you can Google battle of shock valley and you'll,
you'll start see what,
what I'm talking about.
It's,
it's,
it's some heavy,
steep terrain with a damn fortress on the top of it.
I couldn't believe that either.
I was like all of that.
That is a fortress.
How many Afghan commandos did you have with you?
We can start it with right around a hundred of them.
And then,
so my team,
you know,
so I go through it in my head,
I was about 12 dudes when you,
when you add it all up,
we had about a hundred commandos and then we,
we had,
uh,
another SF team that was kind of further down in the valley trying to act as a
blocking position in down there and,
and so,
but our main assault force,
um,
I mean,
yeah,
it was about 12 dudes that kind of where that,
that main assaults.
Yeah.
All right.
So,
so you guys,
you,
you look at the plan,
everyone's Kinda like,
hey,
it's going to be steep.
It's going to be tough.
This is what we do.
Let's go get some,
yeah.
I mean,
we made,
we made some,
uh,
like accommodations for that.
Like,
given what we're doing today,
obviously you always want your secondary,
but you know if,
if that Beretta doesn't walk up the hill with you today,
like we understand we got it.
We got to cut some weight.
[inaudible] yourselves down a little bit.
We did pare down,
um,
what body armor I,
we still went with with the plate stolen with still with the helmets.
Um,
and when you're doing those pre combat checks with your,
your,
your effing commandos,
that was always the fun part is they're super motivated to be there.
And I remember one time where
we going and do the pre combat checks with a to 40 gunner.
So he's got a belt fed machine gun.
You carry this,
this is your job.
I started going through and I find,
you know,
the first m four mag on him.
Like,
all right dude.
I mean you don't carry it.
I'm for it.
But I get it.
And we ended up finding,
I think eight or nine informed mags on this dude like Carrie,
Carrie more seven,
six two for the belt fed.
Like,
I appreciate the,
you know,
you want to want to be ready,
but focus,
focus in where I need you buddy.
That's Kinda crazy.
So,
so you guys,
uh,
so how many,
how many helicopters was it that was bringing you all in there?
It must've been a big package.
And did you go in all at once?
Like one giant lift?
It was,
it was,
yeah,
one lift I day.
It was a couple,
couple of Chinooks,
couple black ox,
um,
everybody going in.
And then,
uh,
like I said,
there was another team that Kinda infilled down there with a smaller commando
package.
Um,
and uh,
we had,
you know,
some medical QRF and stuff up in the air if you other things,
you know.
So we definitely had what seems like enough going in.
So you land in there and how long does it take before you realized like,
wow,
okay,
this is,
we took a big bite.
Yeah.
Well I'll,
I'll,
uh,
highlight.
So I was the first guy I get on the Chinook saw that,
that when the last guy to get off,
you know,
just having that responsibility to make sure everybody gets off,
gets up safely.
Um,
and so we hit the zone,
we hear the go and everybody's getting off helicopter.
So incredibly slowly and,
and I'm at the front,
so I'm in the back of the line.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm just yelling at commandos,
like,
get off of this helicopter now.
Like the more time we're sitting here in the morning,
yeah.
If,
if there was a bad guy watching us,
we're just giving him more time to watch us.
Uh,
so it was just taking forever.
And I finally get to the back of the Chinook and I look out and I'm like,
oh,
we're like 15 feet off the ground.
The,
the,
the valley that we're in is just so rocky and so,
such horrible terrain.
Even they're like,
they didn't land like,
oh,
okay,
this is why it's taken so long.
So like everybody else in front of me,
I very carefully,
you know,
sit down and try and ship me off the backs.
I'm not breaking a leg before I even start.
I'm off to a good start.
Yeah.
It started strong.
So,
so we,
we get off the,
the Schnucks fly away and then you just kind of get that rolling that cold quiet
of an Afghan,
uh,
valley.
Um,
you know,
there's that little bit of ice in the,
in the water there,
you know,
it's just,
yeah.
Okay.
You know what you want to use the cliche,
like it's too quiet,
but we do use it the house,
but,
but yeah,
we just got,
we get out there.
How far did you have to patrol up the valley before you were,
you know,
perpendicular to the target building?
Um,
where the target castle because that's what it looks like.
Okay.
I mean it,
you know,
in hindsight and then,
you're seeing up there like,
I mean,
they had fixed fighting positions ready to go for sure.
They were,
it looked like a castle.
they were set.
Um,
I would guess,
right.
400 meters,
600 somewhere and that we got basically we infill just basically trying to use
angles just to make sure,
like we're not that far away.
So if we have some element of surprise,
we don't waste it all but not so close that,
you know,
we're already in it before we get off.
Is that,
yeah,
it wasn't that far.
Uh,
so you weren't on the ground very long before you started.
Did you start,
you took fire from these guys from the castle?
Yeah,
I couldn't,
I couldn't tell you how long before the castle started shooting at us.
Uh,
it could have been five,
10,
15 minutes.
I don't think it was that long.
Uh,
so I was in the other,
the trailing element basically because I was the only us medic on the ground
there.
I had my African commando medics.
But yeah,
I was the only,
only a team medic.
There are,
you know,
SF that you were supposed to have to have this job to have that job to the next.
Uh,
fortunately the,
the other medic on the team had been hurt.
Um,
on a previous mission.
And then while he was recovering from that,
he was in a vehicle rollover,
which didn't help.
Um,
so he got pulled out.
So,
yeah.
All right.
Well,
uh,
hostile do it.
So
yeah,
there's 10,
15 minutes maybe at most,
oh,
we start walking,
walking up there,
you can see the,
the,
the bleed assault for starting to work their way up and,
okay.
Yeah.
Everywhere.
It's super steep.
I'm on both your left and right as you're,
as you're kind of looking at it and they find one little area where you have
those kinds of terrorists,
like farm terrorists has kind of working up and that's where they'd figure it
out.
Okay.
What we're going to work our way up there.
And so you can see them starting to make progress up the up the mountain.
And then ned distinctly remember I saw one dude,
Justin blue,
blue,
uh,
African garb,
sprint across the top of the hill with a,
with a rifle.
And I don't,
I mean,
I don't think he's the dude who started shooting at us,
but I saw that and then within a few seconds everything just kinda opened up on
us.
And
Yeah,
they started,
uh,
one of my little sayings is always take the high ground or we'll take you,
and this was just a situation where you guys,
do you guys do not have the high ground at all?
You guys are literally in a valley.
How long was it before you took your first wounded?
Uh,
it was pretty quick.
so we start taking the,
the fire,
I,
my first job is,
is to my squad.
I Pan commando squad.
So I started getting them situated.
There's not much cover in there.
It's just smaller rocks,
big rocks.
Um,
what would that elevation and uh,
at various points,
I mean both sides were kind of shooting at us.
Uh,
so I start getting them situated and then very quickly,
a haired,
the first call for a medic,
one of the Afghan commandos had been shot.
Um,
luckily it was a fairly minor wound so I ran over to him,
started treating him and while I was working on him just assessing the
situation.
That's when I remember watching many RPGs coming down.
But uh,
what RPG in particular come down,
hit right in front of our lines that the guys were starting to form down in the,
in the,
in the valley.
And then I hear the calls for Ron coming down.
And so I know right away like right Wallen had just been hurt.
Like I just know that right away because before every mission Brian would come
take his squad of the day and stand in front of me and hold them and be like,
this is wrong.
If something happens to me,
find wrong and then you get the next one,
this is wrong.
Something happens.
And so they would,
you know when,
when,
or not calling for a medic there,
just calling for Ron.
I okay.
I know he's squad.
That is.
So
yeah,
it Kinda did that quick math like okay,
this guy,
he's fine.
He's,
he's really not going to live or die based on anything.
I do suck it up.
Grad,
he had a solid grab yourself,
start shooting back,
good luck and ran over towards uh,
were,
had that,
that next call.
And like you had read earlier,
I Find Ryan,
uh,
pleading pretty,
I'm pretty profusely from neck.
And of course now you got a neck injury and you got to go through those quick
calculations.
Like normally how do you stop bleeding?
Lots of pressure.
And I'm like,
well I can't choke them to death,
no tourniquets going to work out.
So yeah,
just that's kind of started the my day of improvising,
like trying to figure out how to,
how to get pressure and I don't even remember exactly what I did.
Yeah,
you just caught caught shrapnel.
I had several shrapnel wounds and the in there,
but you know,
you just doing those quick quick assessments or where there no bubbling,
which means pride in hit airway,
you know,
it's,
it's bleeding a lot but not bleeding that fast that I,
I think it caught a carotid or something like that.
So it was pretty lucky.
Neck wound.
Yeah.
If you have to catch them shrapnel to the neck.
He did it pretty well.
Um,
uh,
so yeah.
Why as I was working on him,
everybody's trying to just figure out what's,
what's going
on the mindsets to we're still assaulting this thing.
Oh yeah.
Dang.
Oh wait,
we didn't just Trump to me in a mental attitude cause I would have been,
oh,
we just got launched by the way you use that.
You said we get low launched many RPGs.
When I get launched many RPGs at me from an elevated position to offer on the
salt in that target.
We're going somewhere else and I got a wounded guy.
Got Two wounded people.
Yeah.
We're,
we're not,
we're not going any further up this hill.
We're shooting RPGs back at him.
We had I on,
I legitimately could not tell you our African commandos real name,
but he just,
he knew his name was Joe Pesci.
Uh,
that's,
that's what we called him.
He looked like Joe Pesci.
He was,
he was our Afghan commando RPG guy.
And so he was kind of like looking at all of us and looking at the mountain and
pointing up there and pointing it as RPG and like,
hell yeah,
dude,
Joe,
make it happen.
And so yeah,
let's see some good fellas right here.
Yeah.
So Jo Beth,
she started shooting back,
so we start getting given back as good as,
as,
as uh,
they were.
Um,
but so yeah,
all that's Kinda starting to go on.
Uh,
you know,
working with Ryan,
trying to figure out what am I,
you go back and get my squad,
what needs to happen.
And that's what I hear on the radio.
The call from,
from up on the mountain that multiple guys,
uh,
we're now now wounded.
I'm
pretty sure the call was that.
And you know,
the three guys at that point or when did so,
yeah,
basically told Ryan,
you're good.
Have a nice day.
And grabbed my stuff.
Just started working towards the mountain.
Um,
uh,
our team team,
Sergeant Scott Ford,
and,
uh,
one of the weapons,
Matt Williams,
they started organizing a response force to,
to get up there and start flexing a little more muscle up on the hill.
So they're,
they're organizing that.
My focus is,
hey,
I need to go.
So,
you know,
we hit the mountains,
start working,
sticking my way,
way up the same terrorist,
uh,
features that I talked about before and,
you know,
it is climbing handover,
hand over hand,
you're literally climbing,
get up to the next terrorist,
figure out how much are we being shot at right now,
where's it coming from?
Where's the next place I can go up and just start working our way up.
Uh,
as,
as we went up,
you know,
the,
the other support element kind of got got with me and we all just started taking
that terrain together.
Hmm.
Took a,
took a while to get there.
I Dunno.
They put out their estimates with,
I don't know how long it took me to get there.
Uh,
got up to the,
the little outcropping that had become,
you know,
where the,
where the command element was.
Well,
it was,
and
start processing the situation that we had.
Uh,
right as I,
right as I'm looking at it,
I can see,
uh,
one of our interpreters,
c k he appears to be gay.
Um,
two of the two of the team guys,
we're down with the
different wounds.
And so I started just trying to go through the fastest yeah.
Triage that I can to figure out what I need to do.
And,
and mean,
honestly,
even at this point where I don't think the calls may quite yet that we're,
we're done for the day,
but it was going to be,
it was going to be called very soon after that.
Um,
so yeah,
trying to remember the f the full sequence.
It was a busy day.
Um,
so I think I started working on Dylan first just because he looked the worst
off.
He had a gunshot wound to his right arm and then another one to his hip pelvis
area,
his,
his armor.
And I joke with him now because he's good,
he's fine.
And it's okay to joke about getting shot after the fact.
But you know,
joke with them that,
you know,
that w at one board,
the hit his arm,
uh,
it was,
it was just a,
uh,
lucky bullet for him,
but it went through his,
his um,
ah,
forgive me,
just speaking words is tough sometimes is a raise,
a rifle,
a strap.
It went okay.
Sling,
they went through a slang cut cut that then went through his arm and then he
chose to keep his pistol on that day.
But at the time we were still kind of running a pistol on the front of your,
your body armor.
Yup.
And so it had actually lodged in between his plate and his,
his pistol.
He hit the inside of his,
his pistol or that,
just a slightly different angles on that bullet and yeah.
Yeah.
So his,
his arm wound was basically just a very minor bleed.
Didn't worry too much about that,
uh,
but didn't take me long to figure out is,
is his other one was going to,
going to be
literally a pain in the ass for him all day,
uh,
figure it to the League for me.
Uh,
but it was,
you know,
you could just see the way it's bleeding and it's just,
those very small wounds entry.
Um,
so I made the,
I made the,
I would say dunk call for just a few moments.
I don't even know how long it was.
Uh,
I didn't want to roll him anymore than I had to,
to just see what was going on.
Uh,
so I for a little bit,
took my home on,
off,
set it to the side so I could just roll him just to see the downside wound.
How bad was it?
Uh,
didn't end up being that bad,
so we're going to roll them back over and helped me up on my helmet on right
away.
Or maybe somebody yelled at me.
Uh,
but so just started working on trying to figure out how to get pressure on
there.
You'd mentioned we had the WHO combat camera man out there with us,
uh,
by that point is Cameron already been shot.
So he,
he just became an extra,
an extra set of hands for me to,
to help.
So I'm like,
okay,
let me go with triage the rest of these guys real quick,
just hold pressure here for me.
I'll be back in a second and
now I say I'll be back like the area we're working in,
which was not
that big,
it was
maybe 20 meters across and it's just that that slight slope you get on a
hillside before it falls off the cliff so to speak.
Like,
and everybody's just talked up in the hanging on that tiny little bit of a slope
trying to not fall off and not get shot.
And the,
the guys had been shot with a on that soap and they got shot with a pushing up a
little bit.
Will you,
will you somewhat safe in that shot where you're in that spot where you somewhat
protector was guys don't get,
I guess they weren't cause you,
you still guys were getting shot
guys.
We're still rolling,
still getting shot the whole time.
Uh,
so we're,
we're basically,
you're just trying to use that tiny bit of an angle to minimize how much you can
be shot.
There was,
there was no place where you were safe on there at all.
Um,
if you kind of
picture like from from,
from that little outcropping where we were,
if you're looking at the main village,
it was almost like a,
like a hockey stick kind of in front of you is the way the mountain kind of
wrapped around.
So yeah,
that long wall kind of on what I'm considering my left,
but then it still wrapped around,
so the whole village,
if you've got a little bit of cover from this side,
you're exposed to the other side.
The other side still had you.
And then there was some people on the other side of the,
the valley who were shooting this too,
but it was much,
it was insignificant compared to other problems we had.
Was your mindset at this point totally focused on just getting the Gore get
working on the guys.
Did you go into that mode?
Like of,
okay,
this is what I got to do,
or wars,
any part of you going,
ah,
this is not good.
D did any,
was there any party that was saying,
hold on a second,
look what's happening.
Situationally were surrounded,
they have the,
the enemy has the upper ground.
I got won't three wounded guys.
What calls being made?
What,
what was,
what was like your tactical assessment of what was happening?
Uh,
or were you just straight up a working on guys trying to save their lives?
From my perspective,
it was straight up working on guys,
uh,
at that point,
the trying to get my commandos and you know,
leading them anywhere that was over for me.
Um,
I would,
I would find them hours and hours later and they were like,
they were still down in the valley,
just hanging out,
trying to use a little bit of cover.
And they all kind of saw me and they're like,
we thought you were dead a while ago.
Welcome back.
Uh,
you're like,
thanks for the support.
Appreciate it.
Yeah,
thanks.
So I just said we were working on closing those gaps with them,
but we're sometimes the other advanced I'll broke.
Uh,
but so yeah,
I was mostly focused on just trying to treat these guys.
Um,
and
you know,
you need to convey information to the team leader and you need to tell the guy
you're,
yeah,
you're fine buddy.
You don't,
don't worry about that.
So at one point,
you know,
I'm John Dylan,
you're good dude.
We walked us off and then you kind of looking over the team leader meeting like,
no,
seriously,
he needs to go back and right now he needed to go a while ago,
but now we'll be fine too.
Um,
so,
and
I didn't really think about his perspective on it,
but you know,
later he's like,
yeah,
I was hearing it all to Mike.
Sorry about that.
That's,
that's a,
a rough way to hear things.
So,
so you had three guys wounded that position as well.
So there was the,
the,
the three kind of a knit,
the g two O two Americans initially credit critical and uh,
the one EC in and I,
so I started working on Dylan,
went over to Luis,
saw what,
what,
what had happened to him,
Luis Morales,
um,
and he had been shot through the thigh and through the ankle and both on the
right side.
And luckily it didn't hit any of the major vessels,
but it like four,
this is diet.
It just ripped it in half.
Like you could look all the way through,
just dial,
looked like you'd cut up and a fish and you were gutting it.
Um,
so while he wasn't,
you know,
he didn't hit a major artery.
It's just so much tissue damage that the way this could still form compartment
syndrome gets,
they'll kill him many different ways.
So I start working,
you know,
assess him and you know,
just doing those first sweeps,
like I'm not trying to do anything definitive yet.
It's just like,
let me figure out what all is going on and then I'll come back through.
Uh,
so after seeing Luis,
I still felt like I owed CK an actual check.
Um,
this is the interpreter,
the interpreter,
he was,
he was dead,
but I still owed him,
like
unless I know what killed him,
maybe he's still alive.
Uh,
so I went up to the,
checked on him.
He'd,
he'd been shot just behind the left ear and yeah,
it was,
it was an unsurvivable wound.
Um,
yeah,
so I checked on,
checked on him,
and then,
you know,
we just,
unfortunately,
with as little cover as we had for anything,
like he couldn't take up space where we had cover.
So we,
we just kind of had him off to the side a little bit,
uh,
but exposed to the elements because,
you know,
unfortunately the living guys didn't have enough space.
So after checking on him,
I kind of go back through and obviously this entire time we're still getting
shot out.
You can still feel those spirits gone by.
You could still feel the dirt kicking up.
Uh,
yeah,
there's,
there's just,
everything's so tight in there and so little space,
like I'm trying to kneel over these guys to
do the best I can for them.
And,
and as things are just falling on us or trying to cover them as things,
you know,
just rocks are coming down,
explosion,
they're happening.
Just trying to get at some point they start calling in for fire.
Is that,
is that happening yet?
Uh,
the,
the uh,
calls for fire came in,
they started pretty quickly.
Um,
Zach Reiner was our air force combat controller that day.
He got the Air Force Cross.
Very deservedly so,
uh,
being,
you know,
all of us are alive because of all the stuff that he called in the day.
Yeah.
Um,
he's dropping bombs,
danger close,
drop them 2000 pounder.
I mean,
he,
he's dropping the stuff and again,
you don't want him talking about this as if I knows or what it looks like.
Cause I saw you can watch these videos and you can see the bombs hitting in
massive hitting that castle and massive bombs hitting that castle.
And even,
even the bombs had hit that castle.
They day they do damage,
but that castle was massive and crazy.
You know,
we ended up through the course of the day,
um,
one of our Afghans,
uh,
broke his leg,
the wood framing on a building,
they got blown up,
broke his leg.
So we gotta we gotta deal with that.
You're getting just all the other wounds that are coming,
uh,
with those.
Could this cause massive debris is coming down on you guys from those danger
close hits,
bomb drops and it like debris is coming down on you guys because you guys are
below it down a cliff,
right at,
at one point,
I don't remember exactly where in the sequence of events.
Uh,
basically I can say we kind of had that wall on our left that went straight up
and there was,
there was a building there and they were getting in that and starting to just
shoot down at us.
And so that had to go away.
So,
uh,
Zach ended up calling in a strike,
hit that.
And
I don't go hunting too much for footage online,
but I don't,
I've seen it through the military side.
You can,
you can actually hear the pilot come on the radio after he drops that one.
He's like
not feel good about that one yet.
That's how danger close it was.
It was so dangerous.
Close at the pilot,
comes on the radio afterwards and says he goes,
that was real close.
I don't feel good about that one.
Meaning you could hear the,
the sickness in his voice thinking,
how do we just kill our own guys?
You just killed everyone.
And of course
for us,
you know,
we're covered and we're getting covered in debris.
We're getting just rained on stuff.
But we're like,
thanks dude.
Talk totally insane.
So at what point did you guys decide,
okay,
we gotta get Outta here?
Uh,
or were you still thinking of it?
Maybe we'll just get done with this assault up the hill.
At that point,
we're pretty much done at that point.
Um,
so Scott,
for his name sergeant,
he comes in,
like I said,
he,
he was,
you know,
right there with us moving up the hill,
uh,
bringing on those,
those extra guys.
And he started,
I'm working on trying to keep these guys alive and he starts to working that,
let's get them out of here.
Peace.
Um,
so our lead element,
it actually made the edge of the village and like,
I think they got into at least one building and so they're starting to hope we
got that foothold.
Like we,
we made it guys,
we were mine.
Uh,
but so he makes that call.
Okay,
we got,
we've got to pull those guys back.
Yeah.
To start getting,
which is actually incredible to even have gotten to that.
And,
and to be honest with you if things,
now that I'm,
you know,
I'm talking about how much I would've just,
bailed out of there.
Once you get a foothold in that situation,
now it's,
you know,
it's going to be CQC,
us against them.
Like you,
you actually have a pretty good chance,
you know,
well,
you got a hundred commandos or we get 'em up that hill,
you get a foothold in that building.
It's like,
okay,
we're not in that castle.
We can start taking it out.
So that's,
that's impressive man.
Props to you guys for sure.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
fortunately as bad as it's started
for quite a while through the day,
it actually,
it kept getting worse.
Like it never stopped.
Um,
I think we started to get some laws after we'd done so many airstrikes,
but,
uh,
so the,
the side of the mountain that I went up a little bit later in the day,
like it was just no man's land.
You didn't go over there if you wanted to not be dead.
Um,
so the logistics of trying to get an actual fighting for us,
even though we had a foothold,
it,
it just became an untenable position.
So,
you know,
I'm working on these guys.
I'm,
I'm trying to get some kind of hemorrhage control,
bleeding control on,
on Dylan,
uh,
B,
no,
with Louis,
I didn't quick,
uh,
quick treatments on him.
Got His bandaged up as well as I could,
so that way.
Yeah,
just we'll all that trauma.
He didn't end up,
you know,
still stuff dying on me on the mountain just from,
from some something.
I'm still working on Dylan and said it
based on what he was describing to me.
Like I didn't see the point of like,
yeah,
they in the medical arts they teach you like,
oh,
you can,
you know,
you press on a pelvis down and then you squeeze it and that's how you'll see if
it's broken or not.
Like I didn't see the point in doing that to him just where the wound was.
Like something in there is broke.
Uh,
he's not going to benefit from me jumping up and down on it,
just on it of define our good dude.
You're,
your pelvis was broke.
Sorry about that.
Uh,
so,
eh,
but he was also describing like,
oh,
my foot doesn't feel like it's straight.
Like nothing feels like it's lining up.
Right.
And no,
it wasn't because the,
we'd find out later that,
you know,
the boy had gone through is for moral head.
Um,
so shatter that did a bunch of damage to the,
the pelvis itself.
Um,
so I'm just seeing this site,
you're looking at what I,
what I can physically see Emily.
I don't think it hit an artery,
but if it hit the pelvis,
and it's been a while since I was a medic,
but you know,
I remember having those,
those numbers in my head like,
okay,
a pelvic fracture is going to cause this much bleeding and a for moral factor is
going to cost this much bleeding and trying to process those things like,
okay,
he's not,
he's not bleeding out,
but he's still gonna bleed out on me.
Uh,
so it was so high up you couldn't put a tourniquet on it couldn't really do
anything.
So it just came up with the idea that I had a cell ox,
a hemostatic agent.
It would designed to stop bleeding.
I had a
powder of that.
So what I did it,
I just kinda started pouring that on the wound and then taking my fingers and
shoving it into the wound because the wound was so small.
Entry.
Windsor.
Yeah.
Not Big.
So to start shoving that in there,
trying to get as much in as I could and just repeating that process over and
over until I felt like I had enough.
I don't know,
just it was just the scientific,
just just kind of gut call,
shoving fingers in your buddy,
be like,
hopefully it will help.
Uh,
then wrapped them up as well as I could.
And so while I'm doing this,
that's when the lead element started to get back towards us and they were going
to help us start to get these guys out of there and within
moments,
minutes,
whatever it was of them getting,
getting there.
That's when we took our next American casualty.
John Walden had been hit mother right?
Rightly just below the need,
basically stay amputated his leg right away.
It was hanging on by a little bit,
but it,
it just amputated it.
Um,
so the hemostatic agents that are out there,
they've gotten better now,
but at the time it was,
you know,
you have to hold pressure for five minutes,
otherwise maybe the clot will break and then now he's going to bleed inside
there and you'll never see it.
And so started yelling at somebody,
get a tourniquet on him.
They do.
And now he's just stacked up,
you know,
taking a more,
more,
uh,
real estate for us.
Uh,
so our team Sergeant Scott,
he's trying to figure out,
okay,
now we have,
you know,
another casualty.
So we,
we,
we headed to another negative and we lost a positive cause now it's,
that's a dude who can't help move.
And so,
you know,
at that point he's very,
I know at this point it's very clear we're,
we're done with the mountain.
We just need to go home.
Uh,
so yeah,
we're still,
we're still working on them.
I know,
I know.
I was working on,
on Dylan and,
um,
Scott ends up getting shot for the first time in the chest plate.
And so I run over to him at this point,
check him.
You know,
I hesitate to say he's fine,
but he's fine.
The jetway did its job.
He's,
he's obviously going to feel that for a few days.
Uh,
so I go back,
keep trying to package up these guys a little bit more and we're just,
you know,
it's,
it's tough not to gloss over like
minor wounds.
Like,
you know,
this guy just got more shrapnel wounds,
like quick check,
you're fine.
Move on.
Um,
one of our commanders at some point in all of this,
another one of our commandos got shot in the head.
Um,
he dropped instantly.
I'm like,
well that dude's a hundred percent dead.
Uh,
but later pull him back over.
And I'm like,
no,
he's actually still alive.
He was,
he just decided to take a little nap out there on the edge of the money amount,
but it,
did you know,
it,
there's weird things bullets do.
It had dented the his head,
but it didn't,
she didn't kill him.
So we're just continuing to just accumulate these problems.
Um,
and so working Scott ends up turning around to say something to us and that's
when he got shot again this time in the left arm.
And it almost amputates his left arm,
but not nothing compared to
the visual image that uh,
John's had had.
And I think it was the same bullet.
Was it a bullet right after on a burst?
I can't say for sure,
but it was at the same time that he got shot in the left arm.
I got hit in the head.
Um,
and so I had my helmet back on at this point,
so I got hit in the head.
And so working on Dylan and I'm trying to ask him like in my,
all right,
like I,
I don't know.
Um,
but you know,
trying to do a blood sweeps are trying to figure out,
okay,
have so much blood or he can even tell everywhere.
Like I don't know if I'm bleeding,
so I'm asking you.
No,
I'm asking him what I'm working on.
Like how am I,
am I okay?
Can I,
can I keep going?
Uh,
but he's like,
yeah,
you're,
you're fine.
Um,
I don't know remember exactly what he said,
but he conveyed,
yeah,
you're fine.
So I grabbed journey get wound.
Yeah.
Luckily,
I mean the helmet,
the helmet did its job,
so it wasn't,
um,
it wasn't,
it didn't do anything to me.
It felt like I got hit with a baseball bat and like just how I describe it feels
like what you would think it would.
Um,
so I grabbed a tourniquet run out to Scott,
put a tourniquet on his,
his left arm.
Uh,
there's just
fall,
there's nowhere to put people.
Um,
luckily he's of of the serious injuries we've,
we're accumulating,
he's the only ambulatory guy.
So basically he self evacuated down the same side of the mountain that we had
come up and you know,
where the fire was,
continue to get worse.
But there was,
there was some guys a set,
Howard and Matt Williams,
they're doing good work over there.
And so basically he kind of got down there and they see him with his arm and
they're like,
we'll get you,
we'll get you taken care of.
So they were,
they worked him down down the mountain on that one side,
but that really only
only worked for him because he could do,
he could move everybody else is,
is uh,
not that mobile.
So,
uh,
Dave Sanders is kind of coming through and,
you know,
he's,
uh,
trying to figure out a route for us.
And so in my mind,
like what I just considered behind me now,
there's basically the cliff kind of just goes straight down,
but like any cliff,
there's,
there's a little terrorists over here.
It was a little terrorist over the Harris.
So he,
he's an exploring that route and he comes back up and ate.
Just comes to the simple,
like,
he's like,
this'll work.
And we're like,
is everybody getting a,
can these guys do it?
And he's like,
they probably won't die.
Well,
that's,
it's
better than that we're at right now.
That's,
that's,
that's a good plan.
So I got this one section of one other article I pulled out.
This is it,
it's somewhere around here.
And again,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
but I just,
this,
this left a really good picture in my mind of what was going on and kind of the,
the how critical the situation knows.
Walton Captain Walton was the,
uh,
was the element commander.
He's the,
the,
and he,
this is,
this is talking about him and he's got some quotes in here,
but this is from the stars and Stripes,
which is like a military newspaper overseas and it says,
Walton feared his force was on the verge of being overrun with the insurgence,
nearing his position,
Walt and reach for grenade and called an a massive danger close strike expecting
it could take out his entire team.
They were all prepared to make the ultimate sacrifice.
He said the bomb dropped and then he saw an image he would remember forever from
that fight,
his body draped over the injured man he'd been working on through the fight.
In that moment,
the strike that we had called in on our own position detonated just above us and
blocked out the sun as the dust settled.
Ron sure was the first thing that I saw on top of his wounded teammates
protecting them.
Even to the end when we had all fully accepted that we were going to go down
fighting Ron sure was still thinking of others.
Yeah.
Like I mean like he says in there,
it definitely,
definitely got to the point where like,
okay,
this is,
this is the day.
Uh,
I don't know how everybody kind of just process that.
Um,
I know for me there was a point where I just said a quick prayer just asking God
to help me.
Uh,
my wife Miranda and our,
our son,
who at the time was a couple of days shy of three months old.
Uh,
just make sure they're cool with,
with,
uh,
what's about to happen
and then just go back to work and just,
you're taking it in little chunks is,
it's too big to try and think of a week
over the course of the day.
May the,
for us critical,
um,
three other US wounded to Kiaa about
13,
14,
15 Afghan commandos interpreters wounded.
And so it,
you know,
in just terms of those numbers,
that's too much to deal with.
But if I just,
you know,
this is the worst thing and going on right now,
I'm going to deal with this and then come up for air and look around.
That's now the worst thing.
So I'm going to over there,
I'm gonna deal with that.
And so you just keep taking it on little chunks,
keep working,
working through it.
At some point you started working towards,
okay,
we've got to get these guys down,
we're going to start lowering these guys down.
So,
uh,
Dave Sanders figure it out.
Okay,
this is,
this is the least bad option.
So I just started getting everybody ready to go.
Um,
kind of started with how many of these guys who were up here,
Luis has a really bad injury,
but he's stable enough.
I gave him a fentanyl lollipop so he's not feeling too bad like you're going
first.
So we got him,
I'd just do a double check on on the guy and then go over to the of the edge of
the cliff and start working them down is,
and depending on how bad their their went,
well like always could help himself a lot.
So like I was getting ready to get them over the edge and uh,
Dave and uh,
why,
why am I forgetting our combat camera guys named Mike Carter.
Uh,
they kind of take them the rest of the way down the hill and then I'd go back up
to our low position.
All right.
Next serious one was Dylan.
Okay.
Getting him ready.
He had,
I got an IV started on,
I've got a few different things going.
I got everything is ready as I could send him over.
All that stuff was ripped out and just mangled by the time we got to the bottom.
But well,
it is what it is.
That's,
that's now what we're the with later.
Um,
so then it came time to uh,
uh,
got over to,
uh Huh.
John Walden,
uh,
started doing an assessment on him
just through the variances of battle.
And,
and everything has his tourniquet.
It had been placed properly,
um,
which is vessel.
Sometimes we'll relax or attention or tense up.
Just so he,
it was at that point,
he's actually brilliant quite profusely.
Um,
so we had to make some adjustments on his Turner,
get get him restabilize just had him
hold his leg,
just give them something to do and you know,
waste that lowered him down the hill.
And as we're,
we're kind of finishing that up,
Mike,
all of the ambulatory commando and interpreter cash these,
they're kind of working their way down through all of this as well.
Uh,
Seth Howard and Matt Williams or had kind of mentioned earlier,
like they came through right behind us just kicking off everybody else that
hadn't got the message.
It was time to go.
Or like CK who had been killed,
they got,
they got him off for us.
The African commando who we
didn't really have a great plan for.
We've got him off and we just got everybody down.
Started setting up of the casualty collection point down there at the bottom of
the hill.
Yeah.
Hawaii,
you're climbing down stuff still exploding.
You still getting shot at.
Uh,
but by the time we got down to the,
the valley again,
it was wait a little bit more recovery.
It was everything that day was just,
this sucks less than that.
So I'm going to do,
I'm going to do this.
Uh,
so at that point,
you know,
we've got everybody off,
got to go through,
recheck everybody now because we've now moved,
moved all the patients,
um,
long since
out of most of my supplies.
So then it comes down to,
well,
you do need a bandage,
but he needs it more,
but you're going to be fine without one.
Uh,
and just kind of keep making those calls.
How long did it take for CAS EVAC to show up?
Uh,
so
we'd never really got,
like,
I dedicated a cas back to come in that day.
We had some black hawks that we're supporting the mission up there,
and those pilots were awesome.
They're like,
there's wounded,
we're going to come in.
It's hot,
they're fine with it.
They know what's going on.
So they came in and we got a,
the first group load it up and out,
and then they came in again and got the next group.
So basically we got all the critical and all the nonambulatory people out of
there and then everybody else just think,
you,
you just got to walk out of here.
There's no other than I was going to come for you.
Uh,
it was at some point around this time when I'm down down in the valley working
is that point that can notice my arm is starting to hurt a little bit and
they just look at my arm arms there.
It's fine,
whatever.
Just,
you know,
if you bang your elbow on something,
you just got to shake it out and you move on with your day.
Um,
it was later that night,
you know,
get back to the base.
Uh,
after we went and saw the wounded guys go and take a shower,
I noticed I have to cut on my arm and bruising around my elbow.
I was like that,
that wasn't there earlier.
Uh,
went and found my uniform and it's got that bullet hole in it.
And I was like,
oh,
I don't have any idea.
It's so important to have around when,
when that went through a
bad,
it just is one of those days like as bad as it was,
you know,
you,
you just an inch this way.
Meaning I think we'd done the math before and it was like we came up with like
eight inches or something.
I can,
if the enemy just could move a bullet eight inches over the course of the day,
like move this bullet one inch this way,
move this bullet this way they
would have just killed everybody.
Like one of the guys got shot through the,
his camel back,
you know,
it bursts that it hit like he had a flare in the bacteria there,
done that.
But at that you just inch that Dylan who had the bullet skim between his armor
and is is Gary.
He moved that and um,
but that's how combat is it how
you train you,
you get is good and proficient as you can.
And then hope for a little bit,
a little bit of luck as well.
You guys and you,
I know you lost two,
well you lost your one interpreter killed.
Well a C K and then one Afghan soldier killed.
Yeah.
Um,
but none of the Americans were killed.
No,
none of the Americans completely.
That's a miracle.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
Uh,
Bardeen he was the Afghan first sergeant.
He was on that SF team knows when the blocking down the valley at some point
they came up to kind of help us do that final policing up of everything.
And he was,
he was,
he was a great forest,
harder for them.
He was leading from the front like he should and he caught around just below
that chest plate is that your order is a Vena Cava.
Doesn't much matter.
Um,
but he dropped and
that was it.
So as,
as rough as the day was and as much as you kinda go through after the fact,
like what could I have done better?
What could have
been here a little fast,
you'd done that shot that guy a little bit
quicker.
The only two
ks there was just,
there was nothing to be done for us.
So I eventually got comfortable with it all because of that.
And then what,
when your team,
what did they even do with your team now?
You guys come back,
you got all these casualties.
Did they stand you guys down?
They send you home,
would they do with you?
Uh,
no.
So after we got everybody,
all the wounded guys out,
uh,
eventually we kind of regrouped and we go down,
back,
back to the infill point,
get them helicopters leave when in a blending it,
some Firebase,
I don't even know where it was.
We don't know if we're going back.
There's another SF team there.
We still got a lot of commandos.
So or like back in the game are we going to go,
um,
I linked up with the,
the,
the medical support that was there,
refit my bag,
got,
got everything ready to go again,
like we were going to go right back.
Um,
but we didn't,
uh,
which was probably the right call for that day.
Um,
so then we ended up going back to Jalalabad,
which is where we were operating out of at the time.
A couple of the ones you guys were there.
So we went and saw them.
A couple of the main guys were already a bog room.
Uh,
we took care of them.
We got a senior,
you know,
they'll see Guy Carl became our new acting team sergeant.
We
just went about better day.
I mean we still,
we still did another mission few weeks later.
Um,
it's just funny.
Remember?
So one of the,
one of the guys,
I'm damn plants,
he's now a sergeant major,
uh,
out there.
Um,
that was his,
his first mission with us.
And of course,
you know,
he's like,
are they all like this?
And of course they are.
Some of them are worse.
Welcome aboard.
Yeah.
Everybody gets some.
And then how much longer was that deployment you guys did?
A few more operations is with your new team sergeant,
you guys went up.
How did you feel going back out?
Uh,
obviously that at by was,
it was different than anything we'd faced before.
You have the,
when when we left,
whatever it was six weeks later.
That was,
that was my last comment.
Deployments or interface,
anything like that.
Again,
but it was,
well,
we went back out.
I mean,
we're ready to go again.
And I remember on that,
that next mission we went out on a,
yeah,
we're going through the village and
our interpreters are just,
yeah,
they would talk with the bad guys on walkie talkies sometimes and they just
talk,
talk shit back and forth to each other.
Um,
and so at one point they were like,
oh,
these were the guys that we just,
I think these are the guys we just messed up a few weeks ago.
Like,
let's get out of my hand.
Then a Kiowa came in and did a run and I took out a few and they were like,
second thought,
let's,
let's call today.
Uh,
I draw.
And now that was the end of that day.
But so,
oh yeah,
that'd be,
it was
definitely a day one.
Never forgotten.
But I'm just glad that,
you know,
the team came,
they got the job done.
We didn't accomplish the mission and we didn't find the bad guy.
We didn't get to bring him back.
But
yeah,
some days the win is,
it's just we got everybody that we could out of there alive.
And
you know,
we certainly gave them worse than we got.
Enemy killed was like 150 to 200.
And um,
and that,
that,
that ended up being the most decorations,
highest decorations handed out for a single day battle since the Vietnam War was
for this,
uh,
operation that you guys went on.
And then,
so when you came home,
what made you decide,
because you ended up getting out of the army,
what made you decide you were going to get out?
I ended up getting out,
uh,
may of 2009,
so just over a year later.
It was
a lot of different factors.
Uh,
like I said,
um,
my,
my older son was actually born in January of 2008 so I came home,
saw him born and then went right back to Afghanistan.
And then,
you know,
we had other missions in this mission a afterwards so that,
that priority,
uh,
factor starts to,
starts to go in there.
Um,
another part of it was just
Gotcha.
Think I always felt like there was something I was supposed to do.
Okay.
And that seemed like as good a good a thing to check a block with is as I could,
I could think of.
I don't know.
It's so many different factors that come in at like I,
there's not a day that goes by that I don't still miss the team is so wish
whenever I hear they're out there,
like I wish I was there with them.
I wish I was,
you know,
still doing it.
But you know,
I felt like I'd done whatever it was I was supposed to do.
And
I think,
I think it's tough for any special operations guys.
See,
oh,
a green baret ranger,
whatever.
At some point you have to hang it up because time is going to,
yeah,
it's a young man
if that game.
So
I felt like,
I mean I'll go out on God on my own terms and so to speak.
Yeah.
And then how'd you end up getting into the secret service?
Like,
what,
what made you look at that and think that seemed like a good call.
So I think I started applying for them when I had about six months ago in,
in the military and trust on,
uh Huh.
So full disclosure with them,
I federal law enforcement just seemed like a good,
uh,
next transition.
So I shotgun blast out,
you know,
the FBI,
the secret service that he,
Yay.
Marshall's air marshals everybody.
And very quickly on,
I really just liked the personality that came with the secret service,
the,
the attitude that the people had,
the dedication of the job though of the focus and a lot of ways,
you know,
like,
like SF,
yeah,
you have super important mission.
Sometimes you have all the resources and needs,
sometimes you don't,
you're still gonna figure it out.
You're still gonna,
you're still gonna make it work on it.
I really liked that personality that came with it.
So
while everybody showed interest in me,
I,
I kind of focused there and end up getting hired with them a couple months after
I got got out of the army
and then we'll all,
it's what's that onboarding like you go through like a boot camp scenario with
them cause they must take kids out of college.
Right?
You're supposed to have,
I can't remember what the book answer is,
like three years of real world experience after college.
Sure.
Okay.
So hmm.
From my glass you had a mixture of,
some people had military backgrounds,
some people have law enforcement backgrounds,
some had,
one was a lawyer,
just any different background.
So is it like a gentleman's course boot camp scenario?
For the most part,
you know,
coming from,
from the SF background,
like
I dunno who we need to kick out,
but you got to kick out somebody,
right.
Just to make sure that everybody else who's here.
No,
it was like,
yeah,
it could happen to you,
but are we had a good class so everybody,
everybody got through.
And,
uh,
but it was,
I won't say he was about three months of training in Georgia at the federal law
enforcement training center.
Kinda basic information,
uh,
criminal investigator training programs and basically
legal law stuff,
how to handle evidence,
all that kind of stuff.
The basics every day,
law enforcement person needs.
And then you continue on with four more months at the secret service where you
learn the,
the two aspects of,
of our agency,
both the financial crimes investigations and the protection aspect.
You're,
most people don't know about the financial crimes investigation of the secret
service.
They don't think about that arm of it.
Well,
and that's,
I mean,
that's why it was created a
President Lincoln signed the secret service into,
into existence to fight counterfeiting because at the end of the civil,
but I can't remember the statistic,
like two thirds of the currency and the country was counterfeit.
Hmm.
You can't rebuild when half of everything is fake.
So he,
yeah,
he signed that and it was soon after that,
you know,
you went to a play,
didn't work out for him.
Um,
but then it was 40 years later that we kind of took over the fall time
protection of the president.
And of course,
that's our,
our main mission now.
Well,
while the majority of people in the agency are,
are out there keeping the financial system secure it intact,
obviously the number one mission is the president of the vice president,
um,
other heads of state or has government that come in to the country.
We protect them.
Ben [inaudible]
mean obviously these are all no fail missions like you,
Ken all let something happen to the president.
Or if you have some country come in that maybe nobody's,
you know,
nobody's ever heard of this dude.
Well,
we still can't let random street violence happen at this guy or,
or something.
So you just,
there's that whole spectrum that you have to work around.
So you get done with the training.
And then where did you,
where was your,
where did you get stationed?
Did you go to the president's detail or did you go to the crime fighting?
Pardon?
So the,
the typical career path is as you go out to one of the field officers around the
country and fight crime for a little while.
So when I got,
got the offer,
they offered me a couple of different studies to start in Phoenix,
Arizona sounded like the best option.
So I took that.
Well yeah,
my wife and son moved out there right away.
We bought a house,
you know,
while I technically live there,
I was off a training for several months and then uh,
join them as soon as I finished up.
And I spent
basically the next four years in Phoenix from May,
2010 to May,
hm.
Doing whatever financial crime or
includes what?
Yeah,
yeah.
Your credit card fraud.
You're counterfeiting.
Did he get your number?
Because credit card fraud people are all about common after me as like open
access.
I think that's what,
and,
and when I talk to people like yeah,
that happens.
It's happened to everyone.
That's like the main crime right now.
When I say,
Hey,
that there's credit card fraud of me,
does he all that happened to me two weeks ago.
It's happening to everyone.
It yeah,
it's happened to me.
Um,
yeah.
Dang.
Okay.
Maybe I won't call you.
It's,
it's one of those things.
I mean there's so many
different low levels too.
I like you can,
you know,
there's the,
the prudence,
the,
you know,
you'll see,
you'll see the thing is like,
oh check a ATM to see if you see a skimmer attached to it,
which is great advice.
It's definitely something,
you know,
something looks weird on ATM,
Joe Use it.
But you go to a store and I mean even like target or these bigger stores.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
They had the massive,
you get hacked.
You didn't do anything wrong.
Like you use the machine,
the machine was a secure your thought,
but at some back level.
So there's those two aspects of the crime that we energies now.
Cause there's the person who stole all the,
the card information,
but they're almost never the person who's using you say they sell it to somebody
else.
So you,
you get to pick which side do I want to chase today?
I don't want to figure out who stole it your own and figure out who's using it
and
kept me pretty busy.
And then eventually you get called back to DC.
Is that where you got stationed next?
Uh,
so I'm stationed in DC now.
Um,
um,
with the counter salt team for the secret service,
it's okay.
Which is like the cool,
like the coolest job,
right?
I mean in the secret service,
let's be straight up,
right?
There's nothing cooler than saying I'm on the counter assault team of the secret
service.
It does sound cool.
Yes.
And what it really means is sitting in the back of the vehicle somewhere for
long periods of time in a motorcade or something.
Yeah.
With the full body armor on.
Thanks.
So you're uncomfortable,
you're miserable complaining about it.
Like why did I sign up for this?
But then there's like 8,000,
uh,
pieces of security that someone would have to overcome for you guys to get the
call.
But someday,
and it does sound cool.
So we got that going for us.
But what I,
what I loved about that,
just like with Sfo,
you know,
to be there,
you have to,
you have to volunteer,
you have to go through a selection process.
You got to go through another school.
We washed out between selection and the school itself wash out about half,
maybe a little more.
How tight are they on,
are they on shooting in that school?
Uh,
standards are much higher than the general secret service
cause you might be taking shots around the president just don't want to throw
that round.
No pressure.
Yeah.
It adds a little extra level to the,
you know,
law enforcement,
every round counts aspects of the military,
you know,
most,
most around scalp.
You can't just fire indiscriminately.
But you know,
if he is generally in that area,
that's why they gave him the more than one bullet.
Um,
whereas,
you know,
the secret service.
Yeah.
I got,
I got in trouble one time during,
during CQC trading for putting down cover fire in a building here.
I was like,
you know,
someone was trying to cross the hallway and I'm like,
okay,
I know there's a baguette.
Other hamsters are shooting at him and um,
you know,
the instructor is like Chaco w w w what were you doing over here?
And I was like,
and he's like,
in this,
you
know,
you're holding this hallway and then you just started shooting.
And I was like,
I was putting down cover fire for the guy that was moving.
He goes,
he's like,
I get it,
but you're really not supposed to do that in CQC.
And I'm like,
okay,
fair enough.
You know,
but if the guy,
because
he wasn't coming around the corner when I was cracking rounds out of it.
Exactly.
So you're so you,
and so you're just,
that's,
do you go on,
is there a rotation that you're going on for that?
Are you like all in all the time?
Pretty three months on,
three months off?
Do you just,
are you just in a certain area and that's when you're live?
So,
uh,
they break us down into,
we call them,
we have teams and then two teams make up a company and then,
and then so we have basically four different elements.
So one's on training ones on uh,
your days ones when you're eating in,
one's on your ear meds had Alzheimer's.
And so yeah,
your,
your downtime is to train and then the rest of the time you're up protecting,
played in the man or you know,
president,
vice president,
other people as,
as needed support,
just always working.
And at some point during,
during that job,
you,
you got you,
you went to the hospital and figured out something that wasn't going too well.
I,
I'd say at least.
Um,
so you know,
if you kind of go through the low,
the full story,
um,
what was that?
Late spring,
early summer of 2016,
I kind of started getting a little pain in my,
my right hip,
um,
a little pain in my back,
but of course I have some pain and I was running around the kit for the army for
six and a half years.
You know,
at that point,
I've been doing it with the account assaulting him for two and a half years.
Uh,
just,
you know,
you're not supposed to do that to your body.
It's not,
it's not good for you.
Everybody knows it.
Uh,
so I was actually in California hiking with the Obama family,
uh,
in your summary,
doing a father's day weekend trip with them.
And Yeah,
my hip was hurting,
my back kind of seized up and I are,
this is,
this is not right,
but I go see my doc and he's like,
I'm just stretch some more
or stop doing your,
your job.
I'm like,
well,
I'm not going to stop so I'm going to stretch some more
pain.
All kinds of guy kept getting a little worse little,
you know,
just a little more knowing as,
as a went
since the doctor to give me a good answer.
Let me try.
A chiropractor got some relief for a little while from that and it,
but it just kept getting,
getting a little bit worse.
And so
he came up with the,
the,
uh,
differential diagnosis to use or medical terms that he was like,
you probably tore some cartilage in your hip at some point.
And I was like,
I don't remember doing that.
And he's like,
well,
as active as you are,
I can just happen sometimes.
So we do an MRI in February of 2017 and then then next day waiting on results
and still fly out to,
I actually flew out to San Diego to do,
to do some more work.
And that afternoon after I got here,
he called the news,
you know,
telling us,
well,
uh,
a few different,
um,
he used the word lesions.
You didn't want to say tumors.
What?
He's like,
he got a few things going on in your hip that are not normal.
I need you to go talk to this doc like as soon as you can.
And
he did into,
didn't even tell me like what the,
what that doc did,
but like,
okay,
he's at this hospital,
he's this dog.
I Google him like anybody wanted.
I'm like,
oh,
he's an oncologist.
Like,
so this like,
of course that calls bad,
but you know,
now we're getting more information.
Okay.
I said,
really not good.
Uh,
I took the red eye back home and next day get a cat scan and that's when they
find a tumor is just everywhere.
Uh,
what they decided was the primary tumor is about the size of a little bigger
than a baseball and my left lung.
Um,
and by that point,
like I started thinking like
with all the work that I've been doing,
like I'm just getting out of shape,
like my runtimes keep you in a little worse.
But at no point did I think that's what it was.
Um,
so we find out like through that Mri,
like I'd actually,
I had a fracture on my pelvis,
um,
Jad baseball on my lung and a fraction of my pelvis
still working.
So yeah,
we go through the process of trying to figure out what's going on,
find a doc,
don't really care for him,
fire him,
go find another doc at Johns Hopkins were really black.
We're still working with him.
Uh,
and we've been fighting for just over two years now.
And then on top of that,
you're,
well as I mentioned,
you guys,
your um,
Oda team got something like,
I don't know,
12 or 13 silver stars amongst them because 10 zero stars,
three or four bronze though the air force cross for this cross.
And you are one of those,
you are one of those silver stars.
Yeah.
So miles and they the the government or,
yeah,
the military.
Basically,
I forget what year is maybe 2015 or 16,
they started doing a,
uh,
a service wide review of all of the awards that had been handed out or awarded
to see if they all all kind of matched up and w w were where they should be.
And I know actually
three of my guys who had been written up for bronze stars,
they got,
they got advanced or they got a raised two silver stars,
but they reviewed year award as well.
And um,
they came to a conclusion that it should be upgraded.
And how'd you find out about that?
So
I of course had heard about the review process that the secretary of defense had
ordered.
Never gave it a second thought,
just went on about my,
my uh,
day to day life.
I mean,
honestly I think like most soft guys,
like just a attaboy and here's your next mission.
That's all any of them expect or want or or anything.
So in uh,
August of last year I get the first call on,
on my own phone because you know,
you still have that as part of that triple play package.
You know,
they get you with the home phone.
Like I don't want a home phone there.
Like it costs more than not have it.
Like the landline.
Yeah.
So somebody,
somebody calls,
they left,
they left a voicemail on that is it is even call a voicemail when it's on the
answering machine,
the answering,
I don't know.
But they called and left a message and they claimed that they were from the
Pentagon and they,
they said we needed to talk to Ron Shirt.
And I was like,
this is,
it almost sounds legit,
but it's definitely a scam.
I'll call him back and just speaking of credit card fraud,
here we go.
So I call him up and they're like,
we need to set up a call between you and a higher ranking dod official.
And so I'm like,
Woo Hoo.
Now like we can't tell you.
I'm like,
why we can't tell ya?
well that doesn't sound right.
So
okay,
go to send me an email from your official.dot mil to my secret service email.
Launch it over there.
We'll just,
just to verify who you are cause you say you're from their army here at the
Pentagon.
I get calls from them all the time.
Dry.
Yeah.
Irs is always calling me saying I'm about to be arrested.
Right.
I used to,
they sent me that message confirming who they were and so I,
I'm just not going to tell me why.
And they're like,
no.
I'm like,
well that's cool.
I got a family vacation I'm taking next week.
Have this person called me after that.
Um,
but like I had mentioned where we're in this
cancer battle.
And so just before we went on that trip,
I started getting some new pain.
So we do some scans,
we find out I got a little bit and a little bit of stuff growing when we make a
plan to deal with that as soon as we get back from our trip.
So I go on my family vacation,
we come back and we start radiation basically.
Then the next day just trying to get control again.
So this person,
the army,
they start calling me again.
I'm like,
Hey,
we're going to set up a date for this person to talk to you.
And it's like,
okay,
cool.
You have any idea right now?
Or are you just now we,
my wife and I were trying to like brainstorm like I knew about the review
process.
Did that even click in your head?
I think at one point.
So
with the,
the email,
like the,
the not substitute,
but I like your name and then this is my job is how important I am.
Blah,
the same as your line.
Uh,
I see that and I see,
see what it is.
So I Google that because I don't know who this person is or what it is just to
get her.
So I started going down that chain and at one point we actually found out that
it there in the long process of the medal of honor.
They're one of the many tears,
but my wife and I kind of look at each other and you know,
just kinda chocolate off.
Like that's ridiculous.
Uh,
but so we're like,
well,
maybe,
maybe you're a witness for somebody.
I got a witness for something.
I signed up for the,
you know,
the burn pit registry that's out there.
Like,
we'll sign up for that.
I'll,
maybe it's something to do with any of these numerous things.
So,
uh,
the day that I'm supposed to get the call,
oh,
teleworking in that day because my just finished up some radiation feel awful.
And so,
um,
I get the first call from the military saying,
are you going to take your call later today?
I'm like,
yes,
I'm good.
Then
one of my friends ends up calling Miranda and it says basically standby for
Ron's boss.
And so he gets on the line to talk to Miranda and he's like,
it's Ron good for a phone call today.
And she's like,
yes,
Ron's fine for a call.
Is this the call that we've been talking to other people about it?
And he's like,
yeah,
you like,
why are you calling?
And we,
we just can't process.
Like why is he now calling us?
So he's like,
are you good for your call?
Like yeah,
we're good for our call.
The army calls me back again.
You good for your call?
And like,
yes,
I'm still good for my call.
I'm going to run out of battery though if you people keep calling me the check
of my good for my,
my call or not.
So a little while later I boss calls back again and he's like,
your call is canceled.
Like,
why are you canceling my call?
And
you know,
just trying to run through all the scenarios in your head.
Like,
Whoa,
why are you doing anything with this?
And he's like,
trust me,
it's good.
And it was like,
I don't trust you
but,
but okay,
I have no choice in this matter.
So he ends up calling and he's saying,
next Tuesday I need you to come into the White House with,
with Miranda and you need to talk to the boss of the president's detail.
That makes even less sense than anything that's been happening so far.
So,
uh,
Tuesday it's September 4th,
um,
we end up,
he comes by,
our house,
gets asked,
brings us in into the,
the White House complex and we go over and we start in the boss of the
president's detail.
We started off in his office and so he meets us in there.
He's like,
you know,
hi Rhonda Miranda,
thanks for coming in.
Really appreciate it.
Um,
John Kelly wants to talk to you guys.
So of course Miranda and I are kind of looking at each other like trying to do
like has,
he knows like,
and kind of what we're,
where are we,
we landed is like,
okay,
I think I'm going to get upgraded to a cross,
which is an amazing honor,
I think.
And I think the secret service found out,
and since John Kelly,
the chief of staff at the time,
you know,
former general,
we had that connection,
like he's got to,
he didn't bring me a gel me.
So we spend some time in the boss's office and they bring us into the waiting
room and in the west wing itself.
And so we're sitting there just continuing to wait.
And then,
uh,
John Kelly comes by and he's like,
Hey Ron.
Hey Miranda,
thanks so much for coming in.
I just want to talk with you guys for a little bit.
And so he's like,
follow me back to my office.
So we start following inquiries.
So we started following him down.
Miranda doesn't know the White House,
so she's just tagging along.
Like we're walking down the hallway and I think,
think we pass,
uh,
Sarah Huckabee's office and she's like,
oh look,
she's just,
you know,
going to be kind of star struck by the,
by the office and all the things.
But in my mind I'm like,
you know,
I don't want to interrupt the chief of staff to the president,
but I'm like,
sir,
your office is,
is that way?
Like,
do you know where you work?
Uh,
but I'm just along for the ride.
So we walked down the hall,
we make a couple turns and then he makes that left into what I know is the Ole,
and so I get to that threshold.
I see the president sitting at his desk and as soon as I hit that threshold,
I can see there's cameras.
So the video and you're just still camera is just going crazy,
just white house,
internal stuff,
just clicking away.
And at that point it was definitely like,
oh shit,
this,
the Naco today gone and got out of hand.
Uh,
so the president gets up,
he shakes her hand.
You know,
you did not expect to see me today.
Did you know it wasn't,
I wasn't planning on it.
Uh,
I honestly can't remember everything.
You know,
just the usual platitudes.
Thanks for your service.
I heard you were in Afghanistan,
like,
yeah.
And he's like,
did you know you're getting looked at for Afghanistan?
And like,
no.
He's like,
well,
just want you to know I just approved you to get the congressional medal of
honor.
And honestly at that point it all just kind of went to white noise.
I couldn't,
I don't know what else he said afterwards.
Um,
we have the pictures and you can,
you can flip through and you can see the moment where he tells,
cause I have a definite what the are you saying?
And my wife is starting kind of that happy,
happy cry.
Um,
but yeah,
so we had had no,
no idea that it was getting,
I mean I knew generally that things were getting looked at,
but I'm no idea that my packet would stand out or not stand out or,
or anything.
Um,
yeah,
we,
we got out of there the,
the,
the boss that had
basically
found out it was,
you know,
government efficiencies.
Like that day I was supposed to get the call,
they kind of went down the hall and like,
does this guy work for you?
I've been emailing you from a secret service email address for weeks now.
Uh,
but so it was at that moment,
they're like,
does he work for you?
And they're like,
yeah,
he works for us.
And he's here in DC and he,
oh,
he has a White House pass,
he can walk in a little White House.
And it's,
I mean,
once,
uh,
so,
so they coordinated that.
They made sure the counter assault team for that day,
they were all,
uh,
you know,
marine,
a green baret some more army.
And when the Marina,
just all army guys who all kind of got it.
And then they found out,
like
as I was finding out and so went and saw them and he had the whole,
whole thing was just super surreal trying to
figure out why me,
why,
why not?
Why any of it.
Um,
I remember it was soon after that,
the,
uh,
the crawl from depending on,
she called,
she's like,
so you've obviously not talked to him,
you know,
you,
you know why we were being secretive now.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And then she said a lot of stuff about like,
you know how the process is going to work and other things.
And at the end of it,
it got to the point I was like,
ma'am,
I don't remember a thing you just said,
but I don't have a uniform.
And like I don't know why that out for seven,
eight,
nine years or something,
make them age thousand nine is when I got out.
So this is me.
That's nine and a half years.
Yeah,
next month will be 10.
So that was nine and a half years since I got out.
So yeah,
it was the last thing that I thought was,
was coming at me.
I'm obviously
super humbled by,
by it,
but it was definitely the last thing I thought would come my way.
I still remember feeling
almost guilty calling my teammates to let them know.
So I'm like,
Hey,
can you,
can you come to DC on October 1st?
Because,
um,
I'm getting them at a lottery and I felt like I had to apologize to them.
Like the team was amazing that day.
The team did everything and a lot of these guys,
you know,
kept going for years and years after I got out.
Like,
okay,
I don't know why I'm getting this.
Hmm.
Where else?
It's,
it's awesome.
And I'm sure they all thought to themselves,
well,
uh,
that maybe the fact that you saved my life and kept me alive might be the
reason.
So yeah,
that's a unbelievable,
awesome story.
Um,
and it sounds like there was definitely some good smooth government operating in
there as well.
They worked out.
It worked out to be pretty good secret.
Pretty awesome that they get it from you.
You know,
after we stepped out of the oval,
you know,
John Kelly,
he's like,
sorry I had to pull a trick on you.
And he's like such an honest guy that he guilty about that
green,
like such a good guys.
I am really sorry I had to do that.
It's okay.
I forgive you.
And then,
um,
how,
when,
when you go talking about the cancer a little bit,
when you go in for radiation,
when you go in for Chemo,
like I,
I,
you know,
I've known people that have gone on chemo port,
it's like crushing,
uh,
physically.
Uh,
so
with,
um,
with my treatments were in a hurry assessment phase right now to figure out what
we're doing.
But the last couple of years I've been on,
uh,
said,
okay,
it's super,
super far out in the weeds,
but it's a targeted therapy for my,
for my very specific kind of lung cancer.
And so I take one pill every day and yeah,
it's got me two years down the road.
Uh,
so it,
the,
there's ups and downs with it.
Um,
some,
you know,
definitely some side effects.
I think generally speaking,
it's better than what you think of his chemo.
Um,
I know it's a pissed off a lot of
keyboard warriors and the sergeant majors out there in the world.
Like I didn't shave for the,
for the ceremony and I was like,
well,
cause I had a,
a rash from,
from my treatment.
So I physically couldn't shave at the time,
but some people took offense like,
sorry,
really?
I want,
I,
I want it.
It,
it was,
you know,
I just,
it's awesome.
That's only in America.
Could you say,
oh that guy got the medal of honor.
You might want to shave next time.
That's,
that's professional jealousy yet it's Fido straight.
Yeah.
So I made it,
we try not to chase down to many the people,
but a few of them are like,
oh,
just so you know,
like this is why I have a nice day.
Mean what are you doing day to day now?
So are you still,
do you work?
Are you working right now?
Secret Service?
Do you have to put any time with them or you aren't like some medical leave
right now?
Did you stay in the secret service?
Uh,
yeah.
I'm still stole the secret service.
Some,
a few people have asked me not what the metal,
like the secret service just to cover.
Yeah.
That's what I did when I was talking to my wife.
You know,
my wife has been talking to your wife and,
um,
I said something along the lines of like,
Oh,
you know,
we'll talk about,
using the secrets of needs and the secret service.
And my wife said,
and my wife's a Brit,
so she wasn't like fully comprehend American government like an American does.
But you know,
I said,
so,
you know,
we'll probably talk about,
him being in the secret service.
And my wife of course,
literally says,
but isn't that a
secret?
So yeah.
Could cover a cover for your,
uh,
covert operations that you are now conducting.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
no,
it's,
yeah.
So once I,
once I was diagnosed a couple years ago,
I just switched over from being operational and counter assaults you when I'm
going to say operations here,
but now I'm in the operations section.
Got It.
So I just send emails to people and um,
I'm a keyboard warrior myself now.
Like you are not working hard enough.
Work harder.
Yeah.
You might want to shave while you're working harder by the way.
And,
and that's uh,
and then you got your,
your wife and your kids.
And how old are your kids?
Uh,
our boys are our older son,
Cameron,
who because I had was,
was three months at the time of the battle.
He's,
he's 11 now and our younger son Tyler,
he's,
he's eight.
So yeah,
my wife has kino multiple fulltime jobs.
You're trying to keep those kids,
you know,
where they need to be when they need to be there.
Like with the secret service.
Um,
I can't remember the exact day count,
but the last year I was like fully able to travel everything.
I traveled like 130 days or something.
And you know,
at least where like the military time deployments,
like you're going to leave in August.
Like,
okay,
that's in the future.
I know when it is,
you're going to be gone for seven months.
Whereas,
you know,
the secret service were dependent on people.
Does the president want to go over here?
If he does,
we're going,
guess what?
It doesn't matter what we had a scheduled next week,
it's going to happen.
Um,
so,
you know,
in 130 days on sound that bad.
It's two days here,
three days there,
a,
call it 8:00 PM.
Tomorrow morning you're on a plane at 6:00 AM get packed.
So,
you know,
she's,
she's been,
she was amazing at balancing all of those things.
I came,
came with a job and then,
then I threw in a monkey wrench with the whole,
I have cancer everywhere.
It's make it more about me now.
So it gives the kids were,
um,
what was that kindergarten and third grade,
I think,
where the ages right?
I know it's like they were just starting to get a little bit easier and you
know,
she's kind of come up for air like,
yeah,
hold on.
I need to,
I need to challenge you a little more.
Sorry.
Well,
it's a,
you know,
sounds like an,
I met her today.
Sinks like awesome,
awesome woman,
awesome family.
And,
um,
I mean,
just a incredible story from,
for everything that you've done and what you've been through,
what you're going through and the perseverance that you're showing is just,
um,
perseverance that you showed and the perseverance that you continue to show is
just,
it's,
it's man and
I'm probably a good,
probably good as good a place of any to try and wrap this up.
Um,
but you know,
man,
thanks for coming on and,
and really thanks for,
thanks for giving me an example to everyone of you know,
how to,
how to train,
how to fight and how to live.
It's a,
it's awesome.
Well,
I appreciate you saying that and I'm not just going to say this cause I'm on
your show.
Like I haven't been listening to your,
you're a podcast for a long time.
I,
I've listened to many different episodes,
but there is one in particular where you,
you know,
you did the book reviews and the a man's search for meaning.
He did that one I think like two or three months after I got diagnosed.
And that was just mean.
I like to think I'm a determined guy and like I can do focus through stop.
But you know,
the cancer battle is definitely very different than an army battle.
Like again,
we get discussed earlier,
like if you could shoot me,
I could show you.
Yeah,
we'll see.
This is that kind of behind the scenes unknown enemy.
And so just,
you know,
hearing about like that book and then I immediately went out and got the book,
read it and like just stuff.
So your body has to definitely,
you know,
not only on those
long boring nights where you can't sleep because this,
this hurts or that hurts like something to listen to.
But it's definitely been very meaningful
to me and in those respects.
So I really appreciate it and
hopefully,
hopefully with someone or too,
you know,
interesting today.
Oh Man.
No Sir.
That's it.
It's awesome.
Um,
and we'll,
we'll keep doing it echoes,
speaking of the podcast,
speaking of,
um,
you know,
taking the fight to the enemy seen and unseen.
Sure.
Yeah.
Big Time.
I know you like to,
you know,
give us some ideas,
some,
some help along that.
Yeah,
I have a question first.
Okay.
So when you got hit in the arm that time that you didn't realize it or whatever,
like what was that like a ricochet or something?
Just the bullet dude.
Yeah.
But like what was it?
You know what happened with it?
Oh,
you mean it's the tiniest little scar you can barely see.
It was like,
like,
uh,
like it just barely grazed you kind of thing.
Yeah.
Grays to me,
when I,
when I got the uniform off,
I mean there was,
there was like,
there was cut,
there was a bleeding,
there was bruising.
Um,
like I said,
it couldn't cause it's a penny.
So much stuff is going on that like boom,
yeah,
you get hit,
but then it kind of gets blended in with all the,
all the rest of the chaos kind of thing.
Yeah.
I mean so much with,
with the,
the air strikes at southern,
we were talking about like,
yeah,
stuff was,
was just hitting you,
falling on you and stuff was,
it was just stuff was always going on.
So
shot,
you know?
Yeah.
You know what else is crazy is I just,
you know,
like echo doesn't ever write anything down during these things.
And you've made that statement like probably like 45 minutes ago,
but echoes has been sitting there thinking like,
Dang,
what happened?
Can we expand on that when my time comes?
I got that question.
I'm coming at you wrong.
Well yeah,
you sort of wonder,
cause he just sorta mentioned it,
you know,
like,
oh kind of like on your book Terminator One,
the first one where they kind of recover from the shootout and then they're
under the bridge and then she started kind of goes,
hey,
what's up?
You know,
he goes,
Oh yeah,
he got me right there and just sort of glosses over it.
She's like,
you got shot.
Like,
oh,
what's up?
That's how I was feeling with you.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
luckily
I did.
Did he get shot at?
But luckily,
not for my sake.
And for Rietta people just not knowing when it was,
it wasn't worse cause it'll be deal.
Keep going about about,
uh,
about the job.
It's crazy now.
Millimeters and inches it inches.
But yeah.
So yeah,
if we're staying on the path,
speaking of which,
okay,
let's start with origin for gin up in Maine.
American made company,
American founded company.
It just an American company.
I think their sums it up.
Excellent.
But they go deep with American made though.
That's the thing.
True.
So anyway,
so you're doing Jujitsu,
which we all are.
You want to gie,
you get it from origin,
all made in America.
Nngugi out by the way out.
A real good on.
Have you used it yet?
I know you're kind of off the,
did you get to for a little bit,
got a little,
uh,
got a little dinged up in the knee area,
but you used it.
Yes.
Good assessment.
Solid.
Legit as we sit in the,
in the history.
Yeah.
Yup.
Uh,
also rash guards on there.
Even the,
you know,
the existing ghees are good,
are exceptional actually.
They're the best in the world.
Factually made by Jujitsu people in America with American made products.
How much your items did you do?
How much rolling did you do?
We did.
Uh,
we did a fair amount and then at some point,
like I mentioned one that you teach art and showed up and kind of reset the way
we were training.
Uh,
we did a little less rolling and he found some guy just outside Fort Bragg.
It was like,
I just met him fights in,
I think it was from Miami.
He's like,
I've been in fights in Miami for you for years and years and he's really good at
it apparently.
Uh,
so we did a little less rolling with him cause he,
you know,
he kind of brought up the point like with all this stuff you're carrying,
if you end up on the ground,
that's not a good day for you on the ground and you better know what you even
with all that stuff on.
Yeah.
We,
he,
he kind of taught us a different way,
you know,
a fighting if you get on the ground.
Yeah.
Get back up as quickly as you can.
The primary,
the primary purpose of Jujitsu in self defense situation is to get up and get
away from him.
Not to put a triangle on them or put up some kind of uh,
you know,
pull guard,
guard on the guy.
Like that's not smart negative.
The other funny thing is
like I was,
you know,
I was talking about Jujitsu being important and all that stuff,
but like in the seal teams,
people would get really into combatives,
which is cool.
I'm down with being in Madison,
I am totally into combatives.
I'm totally into MMA and Jujitsu and wrestling and boxing and a tie and whatever
else I can find that is effective.
But if you have a choice between being really good at shooting your guns and
being really good at are unlocking people,
if you're in the,
if you're in the military,
it's better to be good at shooting here.
Guns.
Now,
luckily I'm here to tell you,
you can get good at both,
but prioritize being able to shoot really well.
Most of my workouts and now with with the whole cancer thing or just locks.
But no,
maybe I'll check out one of these keys and just walk around.
Oh,
we can get your leg.
Well we get it all.
Get your keys for your kids too,
cause your kids should be doing Jujitsu.
That's for sure.
If I agree.
But also on there,
they have other apparel items fashionable.
We don't know.
You don't use the word the word.
He doesn't like the concept.
I get it.
But the fact remains,
Pete,
he knows that the peak Robert's founder of origin,
those a little bit about Pete,
my partner up in,
uh,
up in Maine,
he's got like a little,
he's got a little fashion sense to a little spring course,
which I have zero.
So there's a contrast there.
You know,
people talk about a color.
Yeah.
As long as it's black or gray or I get it.
So anyways,
anyway,
also supplements what best kind of supplements,
joint supplements.
Apparently when we were young,
we're about the same age.
I've estimated.
When were you born?
78 so I just turned 40.
So you're one year younger than me on the list.
Back when we were young,
we thought,
what protein supplements,
right?
Create.
Remember when creating him,
everyone's like,
hell yeah,
that's the team.
That's so much of that stuff.
As it turned out,
oculus not even as important,
not even nearly as important as joint supplement.
So Jocko of course,
makes supplements.
Jocko,
joint warfare for what?
Anti inflammatory stuff.
Glucosomine constraint.
Super Krill oil.
Krill oil.
Very important for your joints.
Um,
keeps you in the game.
Even at our age,
I am tripling up on joint warfare right now to help the recovery process of my
knee.
Oh yeah.
Men,
the joint where and the Krill Oil Combo,
whatever.
When you're consistent,
I mean you could stay consistent.
So I get it,
but I have a experience with inconsistency.
So when,
uh,
when I get consistent,
man,
it's like you're on this like road,
like he,
you know,
he could dinged up or whatever,
but like you go,
it's like they heal up so quick and I don't want to make like,
Ooh,
you're like,
what's the kind of the x man guy who heals him?
Sorry,
I'm not necessarily saying you're like Wolverine,
but you feel like you kind of are wolverine.
Like you when you get,
you know how like me anyway when I get hurt or like Dingdong like Dang,
how long am I out now?
You know,
a week,
two weeks,
whatever,
like with this.
And I like,
I don't even worry about it just in the game consistently taking it.
So I dig it.
This is what I'm saying.
Well since you mentioned Wolverine,
I'll say that with my SF and then cancer,
like we spent more time,
my wife and I talking about the possibility that that phone call with somebody
going to enrollment.
Then when we legitimately had conversations
given everything,
you know,
yeah,
you might be a good candidate for this,
this new program and we're putting together my middle daughter,
she watches a those of,
what is it?
Avengers.
So she watches her stuff.
Does that have wolverine it?
Uh,
no.
Right.
No,
that's excellent.
Excellent.
Is wellcare when she watches those things,
but the other day,
and she's also kind of got level right cause he's nine and she kind of went a
little bit of a bubble,
you know what I mean?
And she's nine.
But the other day I started the started,
there's a whole like thing with her where I was kind of tone.
I was like,
yeah,
you know,
cause I was saying all my knees,
I was like,
you know my Neil,
he,
it'll heal up quickly.
And I said,
then I said like I got the little idea in my head of something creative to play
a game to play.
And so I said like,
yeah,
you know it's weird sweetie.
Cause whenever I get injured at Kiehl's up really,
really fast,
it's really weird.
It's always been like that.
Well not always.
And then I started saying,
well you know what time,
it's really weird.
But I had this weird memory of like when when I was in the navy and I went to
the doctor and then I didn't remember things for a while.
And I remember like them putting things in me and her eyes were so big,
she was so stoked for about another minute and she thought I was pulled over
because I started out when you start on when something comes from them,
right.
So it was her that said like,
oh,
how long are you going to be hurt for?
So she initiated this whole conversation.
So that gives me a massive advantage in this trick I'm about to play because I'm
playing the trick based on,
on her reality.
You just came out of the blue,
come on the tray with some trick or some conversation?
No,
it's part of what she asked me out.
You know,
I wasn't just sitting there plotting on it.
Yeah,
kind of.
So that's kind of like your thing,
how you make,
like when you,
um,
when you come up with a plan or a correction,
a plant or whatever,
like how you lead people and I see what you're doing when you do it,
but it still works by the way.
So you lead people to think that they made the plan.
See,
I see that you just did that to your daughter.
She's not by the practiced on her,
but yeah,
that's how I see it.
I get it now.
I get it fully chuck nonetheless supplements mark as well.
Additional proteins.
I still don't neglect the protein,
don't get it wrong.
I just find the joint supplements to be,
somebody asked me on Twitter if I was on growth hormone because of the way I
looked and reasonable though I said I was actually,
it was actually supposed to be a derogatory comment because it was one of those
little clips that someone put up a me talking about something and,
and then someone with the shot,
right.
He made it said,
why would I listen to this guy who like,
he's been on growth hormones whole life.
Right.
And uh,
and I just replied back like I've,
I've never been on any kind of growth hormone unless you count steak.
I have fun,
fun on Twitter.
Twitter is Twitter.
I know you have Twitter.
I don't use Twitter.
I use it.
I'm trying to figure out an Instagram thing.
Twitter,
it makes sense to my brain.
Instagram is also can be fun,
but Twitter is basically just a bunch of one liners.
It's just a bunch of one liners.
That's all it is.
One Line zingers and it's just 24 hours a day.
If,
if you want to sit there and make one liners all day long,
you know that's what you can do with that thing.
That's a good way to put it.
It's just one line and the what's,
what's lame about it or good about it depending on your perspective is if you
and I are having a conversation and you say something and I sing like I,
I hit it.
That took a little quick thinking with Twitter,
you could actually sit there and look at it for 12 minutes.
You could look up words in the dictionary if you wanted to and you can say,
oh,
this is going to be really weedy and you can plan it out.
You can do some research and then you can respond and for all anyone knows,
you just looked at that and just threw it out there so you can just got the
notification.
Yeah,
you just saw it and I'm just throwing out this advanced shot back at you.
Whereas the reality is that's not what happened.
So it's a really interesting,
now I will say sometimes because I go onto Twitter and I reply like a lot at
once because I don't sit there and look at Twitter all the time.
So then I go back and I just reply really fast.
So a lot of times I will do things that are,
you know,
just like from one team
and occasionally I make mistakes.
You know,
there's someone on Twitter called the,
there's a Twitter thing called grammar police.
What do you mean?
Like an account?
It's an account.
Okay.
I used,
and I was an English major.
Ron,
I know you're an economics guy,
so you're in the numbers and the letters.
So I,
I put your,
and again,
I'm,
I'm tweeting at a 47 tweets a minute.
I'm just boom,
boom.
And I used your y o u r instead of y.
O u r apostrophe.
E
apostrophe Ari.
Yeah.
And so then,
and so then up pops like probably an hour later up pop's grammar police and it
says,
and it's,
it's really,
I actually love the way they do it.
They don't.
They don't,
they don't,
they're not disparaging to you.
They just say for your information,
you used the wrong,
your,
the proper,
uh,
the proper grammar in this scenario would have been to use.
Why are you apostrophe?
Sorry.
Thank you.
And please correct yourself next time.
Signed grammar piece.
So I like the grammar police.
That's a good account thing.
Anyways,
we're going to deep,
she'll like account the Karma police person.
It's not a Bot.
Well he may be odd.
It may be a bot but it's a grammar police account.
You can follow them.
I should probably follow ground release going to what had been pictures they
share though.
Just Twitter.
Twitter doesn't need pictures.
Yeah,
I mean I guess Instagram you could just,
you,
they could've,
they could've blown up a picture.
An image of my incorrect usage of or it would just slide in the comments.
Right.
Cause you wouldn't really,
you didn't need a picture for comments.
So it'd be like true
and then they just slide in the comments.
But they should know that hurts.
Cause like I was an English major.
That's the only way you'll learn though.
We've got to get you some,
a warrior kid milk for your kids run.
Do you do when you were a kid,
did you ever drink strawberry quick?
Yes.
Did you like it?
Okay.
What about chocolate quick?
Yes.
Did you like it?
Okay.
There you go.
Well,
for me it's strawberry quick was kind of like a big thing for me when I was
little kid.
Fake strawberry flavors.
It's so hit and miss.
Yeah.
Well
either one.
If you happen to like strawberry quick,
basically art,
this kids protein drink tastes exactly like that.
It's delicious.
It would be,
it's delicious to me.
It wouldn't be delicious to you.
I guess you'd spit it out.
I would spit it out.
So you'd be cool about it.
Well,
your kids,
hopefully they have better taste buds than you and they'd be like,
Whoa,
this stuff is amazing.
So anyways,
that's where your kid milk and it's,
it doesn't have any sugar and it's actually good for you.
It's got protein and vitamins and probiotics.
It's awesome.
So anyways,
that's that.
Also Jocko at the store,
it's called Jocko store.
That's where you can get apparel.
Jacola apparel
fashionable.
Well,
you know,
you see the dichotomy in this dark and try going there.
The thing is,
it's like,
it's not even fashionable,
but here's the thing I snuck,
I had to in covertly in insert elements,
sprinkles of fashion.
Okay.
Pete,
Robert Style.
Not quite that hardcore but hardcore fans like
yeah,
you're mine everybody.
I'm like Zoolander in your mind.
The um,
so,
so Jockos design,
right?
It's like his thing,
it's like not even designed,
the font he uses is like computer font,
literally not so it's like OCR,
whatever.
So he's like,
you know what discipline equals freedom.
You know,
we'll put it on a shirt and I'm like,
cool.
So I look at him like,
okay I dig it but it,
Lisa made the shirt like the shirt material.
It's like,
you know,
a bland and all this stuff.
It's not like some cheap,
uh,
what do you call like a boxy,
rugged,
I don't call it anything.
I call it a shirt.
Yeah.
See and that's my point right there.
See what I'm saying?
So that these items are going to be super basic,
non fashionable.
But when you get the apparel,
you can be like,
oh,
this is really wearable stuff.
There's really nice,
that's what I predict.
You'll think,
you know,
if,
if history is any indicator.
But anyway,
a tee shirts on there.
We've got some lightweight hoodies on there.
Which Jocko,
are you even down for the lightweight hood?
Because so far people,
everyone know every single person who was like siding with Jocko in real life.
I'm not talking about Internet siting with Jochelson.
Yeah.
Hoodies or for like when you're cold you need uh,
uh,
a heavy hoodie.
Otherwise,
why are you even wearing a hoodie?
Just wear a shirt,
right?
Everybody know everybody who
is just ridiculous.
The lightweight Hoodie have changed their mind.
Every single person's mind.
Dave Berman be all good deal,
Dave.
Oh heck yeah.
Yeah,
I was wrong.
This hoodie is outstanding.
Oh yeah.
Actually I already knew that.
That's why we did it.
Like we'd hoodies shirts without rash guards for Jujitsu and otherwise and life
man.
And uh,
you know,
some women's stuff,
hats,
all some cool stuff.
I think it's cool.
People seem to think at school going there.
He likes something,
get something.
Chocolate store.com.
Ron,
how'd you like that?
How'd you like the tea is really good.
Definitely.
It's the best team you've ever tried.
It's better than strawberry quick.
It's way better.
Definitely would drink this strawberry click mean if it has the extra benefits
of the probiotics and the protein,
maybe I'll drink a little extra,
but cool.
If it's just strawberry quick.
Now Ron has been drinking Jocko White Tea with pomegranate.
Anyways,
certified organic by the one good thing about it is it after you finish this,
can you can deadlift 8,000 pounds and that's,
that's proven.
It's proven fact,
100% proven.
As a,
as a former former 18 delta medic,
I can help you run through the test and you'll see it's 100%.
Uh,
make sure you're subscribed to the podcast if you don't subscribe to it already,
which is kind of ridiculous,
you know?
Yeah.
Let me,
Oh yeah.
Oh and I just read review.
Yeah.
A Guy said
he was going through like his top five podcasts in the,
and then our podcasts came into his world as this is the podcast that I most
subscribe and unsubscribe to.
Okay.
And he says,
I subscribed to it because it's got great information on leadership and human
nature and history and war.
He goes,
but I unsubscribed to it because they spend a lot of times on some episodes
talking about Jujitsu,
which I don't do.
And this,
this wasn't a review on iTunes.
This was a review that he wrote in a blog or blog and tagged me in it on
Twitter,
his own blog or his own block because people tag you in their blog.
So you'll read it and repost it.
This is great.
So I read it and I just commented back to him.
I said,
it sounds like you need to start doing Jujitsu
later.
So there you go.
Whoever that guy was seemed like a nice enough guy but didn't want to do the
Jujitsu.
That's that.
So yeah,
subscribe and don't forget about the warrior can podcast.
Yes sir.
Oh,
my daughter has a question for the warrior.
Could podcast.
We'll go over it later.
Okay.
Pass it on to uncle Jake if you would.
But yeah,
so yeah,
that's a good one.
Warrior can podcast is,
have you ever listened to one?
Could podcasts where your kids,
it's what it is.
Uh,
the basic principles of life.
I try and convey it in a way for kids that they can understand it,
that they can appreciate it and that they listen to it.
As,
you know,
I'm always quoting you with my,
with my kids,
like discipline equals freedom.
Bright,
right?
Do the right thing and then I'll let you do more.
And you know what?
It doesn't matter who you are as a dad.
Your kids are not going to listen to you as much as you want them to.
So it's good if you come at them from another angle.
The other angle is uncle Jake who can tell them about discipline equals freedom.
So anyways,
where your kid podcast,
check that out and don't forget about that.
Warrior kids soap from Irish oaks ranch.com Aiden's making soap as a kid,
but he's got his own business and he's making soap.
On a rope,
right?
Yeah.
Five 50 court,
little piece of Para Cord.
That's good.
We've got that going on and then you've got youtube subscribe to a youtube so
you can see echoes,
legit videos,
and if you want to know what Ron shirt it looks like,
very handsome by the way.
Then you can watch this complete episode on Youtube.
You can also see echoes enhanced videos,
you know,
it's a lot of time and effort into
them,
which means that he puts a lot of time and effort into them.
There you go.
Yell and it,
some of them are good.
Some of them he puts a little too much time and effort into.
Okay,
cool.
The same.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I dig it.
What else?
Psychologic warfare if you,
I mean if you're having issues,
a lot of issues or just a few issues on the path,
you know,
moments of weakness where you don't want to get up as early as maybe you think
you should and you don't feel like it.
That's what it is.
When you don't feel like it does the little bit of help to push you through any
moment.
Diet stuff,
wake up,
stuff,
workouts,
skipping workouts,
stuff.
That was a big one for me back in that day by the way.
Um,
despite this little scalpel and leg workouts,
not anymore though,
right?
Not the arms were cutting either.
So anyway,
you get this album's called psychological warfare little tracks on there,
Jocko telling us,
helping us through our moments,
a weakness really easily.
100% effectiveness.
My experience.
Cool.
Check out flip side canvas.
It's my brother Dakota Myers,
Dakota Meyer.
He is taking cool shit him images and putting them on canvas vinyl in America
here and sending them to you if you want them.
You know,
he has uh,
a straight up Jocko series now the series,
it's so after anyways,
check that out.
Support Dakota and to what the code is doing.
If you want,
if you want custom stuff,
just hit Dakota up on,
on Twitter cause to is like the nicest person.
You seem pretty nice to Ron but Dakota's really nice.
Yeah and he's always want to help out.
So yeah,
there you go.
Talking about flips on campus.com also on it on it.com/jocko by the way go that
this is where you can get your fitness gear,
whether it be for home,
you got a commercial gym,
whatever you like.
Also some good,
what would you call the elk bars?
Snack food.
Healthy snack.
Even throw the word healthy because the stigma like the cliche like you think
that's the word.
Yeah.
Eating Chalk.
Anyway,
there's a lot of good stuff on there on it.com get something from there to yes,
keep you on the path and in the game as it were,
a bunch of books.
I read a bunch of books.
Mikey,
the dragons that's for younger kids weigh the warrior kid that's for medium aged
kids.
Mark's mission is the follow on to that.
The new book,
three of way the warrior kid is coming out,
it's called where there's a will.
It will be available.
Should be available right now.
How you liked that for preorder on Amazon discipline equals freedom field
manual.
Extreme
ownership.
First Book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin.
Okay.
About combat leadership and how you can apply it to your business,
into your life.
And then the dichotomy of leadership,
which is the followup to that book,
which is also about leadership,
but it gets granular on those principles and on it being a balanced leader,
which is the best kind of leader to be Ashkelon Front.
That's a
my leadership consultancy and what we do is solve problems through leadership.
It's me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
Good.
Yeah.
Good deal.
Day Burke Flynn Cochran.
Mike's Really Mike by Emma and Jason Gardner has relates Jason Garner doesn't
really have a nickname.
He,
yeah.
Oh No.
This is a matter of fact on that one.
A go national in front.com if you want us to come and help you work through
whatever issues you have in your organization,
that will do it with leadership.
The muster coming up May 23rd and 24th in Chicago,
September 19th and 20th in Denver,
December 4th and fifth in Sydney,
Australia.
These are leadership conferences,
events,
gatherings,
musters.
Yeah,
so it's a monster.
That's what we call it.
We call it the muster and if you want to come to it,
you got to register pretty quick.
They all,
the ones that we've done,
these are seven,
eight,
nine this year the all of them have sold out.
So these are going to sell out as well.
If you want to come get there early,
I won't be able to help you.
If you contact me a week prior to the event and say,
Hey,
I really wanted to go,
can you scale,
you know,
throw me a couple of tickets and I know you for,
I went to high school with you or whatever.
I can't help you.
You can't calm.
Don't be mad at me then.
Yeah.
Excellent.
BF on mine.
That is our online training for leadership for people that can't come to the
monster or do you got a big company with 28,000 employees and you want them all
to get trained in the leadership principles that we teach at echelon front.
Go to eff online.com and you can get your whole organization aligned and running
in the right direction.
And we've got f Overwatch as well.
And what we're doing with the f Overwatch is taking proven leaders from SPEC ops
and from combat aviation and putting them into civilian jobs,
civilian sector leadership and don't always think you got to hire somebody that
knows everything technical about the situation.
Hire someone for their leadership capability.
It's easier to teach them the industry than it is to teach someone in
leadership.
So e f overwatch.com that's what you need.
It's you need leadership and if you want to connect with Ron,
he's on the Inter webs.
He's a kind of young on the interwebs.
You're not super advanced.
I'm trying to to,
to learn,
especially
with Instagram.
And so I'm trying to distill it,
dip my toes into that and the toes are being yet
get to get that connection with the people who,
who feel connected to the story at all or,
yeah,
it's awesome.
Uh,
if you do go on Twitter,
it's Ron underscore three nine six for Instagram,
which apparently is Ron's.
Ron is going to be the Graham.
He's in the gram.
That's your main one.
That's,
that's my focus.
That's your focus.
Okay.
It's got the mission focus and that is Raun underscore.
Sure.
And then we also,
uh,
Echo Charles and I are on those as well.
And we're also on
the foss book
and we are,
echo is adequate.
Charles and I am at Jockowillink Echo.
You got anything else?
No,
thank you Ron.
You're the man.
Ron,
congratulations.
Well,
any closing thoughts are on,
so again,
thank you guys so much for having me
today.
Um,
whenever I come to talk about myself,
I get name,
love talking about myself,
like getting most SF guys do.
I'd rather,
you know,
my,
my wife says that,
uh,
you know,
I,
I became a green baret in,
it's the quiet professional,
the,
you know,
you just got you to the mission and you can talk about it.
And then I'm moving over to the secret service,
which is,
you know,
it has that kind of tagline like standing on the sidelines of history.
Like,
I want to do cool things.
I want to be there,
but I never want anybody the talk about me or look at me or do any of that.
Um,
but I,
I appreciate the chance to come here today because we know when I got the,
the metal,
you know,
as part of processing it and trying to figure out what did I want to do with it.
Um,
you know,
like riding a right now from the global war on terrorism,
we've been fighting for 17 straight years,
like green berets.
You know,
that's,
that's where my heart is.
Like they've been just out there,
get it on the entire time.
I'm,
it's mind boggling to me that I am the only living recipient right now
representing that group.
Robbie Miller,
who was in Alpha three,
three,
he was on the same deployment is me.
He won the medal of honor,
um,
in January of 2008,
uh,
barely taking the fight to the enemy,
but unfortunately he was killed.
He was the first Green Brae in this war.
And,
and now I'm a second,
but I'm the first two can actually get out there and share.
I share my story,
not so you can be like,
hey,
Ron's awesome.
Like Ron's just another dude on a team who had an okay day in a bat and a
horrible day,
but store.
So I can tell people that stories like that are going on constantly.
And
you know,
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm here to represent those guys who
don't care.
Do you,
you know,
you could give him,
give him an award,
not giving him an award,
give him a pat on the back.
They don't care.
They just,
they believe in the mission.
They're out there doing the mission,
they're missing birthdays and anniversaries and all those things for this
country.
And you know,
that's why I'm here is just to remind people about those guys,
not so much myself
and
you know,
to be able to,
just share a little bit of that story.
And then,
you know,
also to,
say thanks to my family for being so supportive.
It's,
you know,
I mean I'm,
I got up metal cause I was,
you know,
taking care of other people.
But I have a huge support structure behind me.
My wife,
Miranda,
like I said,
was quizzing me through the Q course elsewhere.
Maybe not our first date,
but by like week two or three and like,
okay,
you're in the circle now,
now you got to help me cause I can't give up a whole,
I want to see you for a weekend but I can't give up a whole weekend.
And that's that.
He,
so just the support that,
um,
she's given from then to now to,
you know,
having a baby or being pregnant with,
with some green baret he was overseas,
he comes back,
sees the baby born like,
all right,
good luck with that kid.
I got to go back and take care of people.
So the amount of support that I've had there and the,
my kids just putting up with all this stuff to just be able to say thanks to
them on a bigger front.
I appreciate that.
And
you know,
I
touch on it a little bit with,
with my cancer story.
Um,
I definitely don't want to be,
I don't want it to be some like
sad story.
Like,
Oh,
this guy has sex to be him or anything.
I just share it just because I know there were other people out there who are
getting diagnosed with cancer and they're getting those phone calls.
And I remember that.
I remember that first call I got where he was like,
you know,
there's nothing you can do today.
And he meant like it was like a Friday afternoon.
I just found out the day before and it's going to the weekend.
But that,
that,
that
crushed of that.
Well there's nothing you can do.
Like what do you mean?
And so,
you know,
the,
if I can just put out that story,
there's always hope.
There's always more you can do.
And you know,
the cancer fight is not like combat where you get to go punch somebody in the
face or shoot somebody in the face and,
and have that like the cancer fight is,
you know,
getting up and eating when you don't want to eat.
And so last thing in the world you want to do or you got to work out well it's
just go for a walk,
you know,
like just,
just those things.
So I just want to,
you know,
have a moment to be able to anybody who's being affected by that,
just say,
you know,
you're,
you're not allowed.
It's tough.
It sucks.
However you got there,
it doesn't matter.
Don't worry about.
I don't,
I try not to worry for myself why I got it.
Um,
but it's just,
it's,
it's just the next challenge.
Keep putting one foot in front of the other and uh,
yeah,
that's life.
Awesome man.
Well,
um,
once again,
uh,
thanks.
Thanks for coming on man.
It's been awesome.
Meet you and thanks to Zack,
you're buddy Zack who kind of linked us up and it was cool that he reached out
to me and it took us a long time to make this happen with everything that's
going on in your world.
And uh,
I'm glad we were able to do it.
So thanks for coming on and Oh,
absolutely.
My pleasure.
Obviously thanks for your service and your sacrifice.
For what you did for this country and you know,
not just for what you did for the country while you were in the military while
you were in the secret service,
but also right now,
setting an example for everyone,
for everyone that's out there for me,
for everyone to follow and know that we can step up our game,
that we can go on,
we can do better and we can fight harder and that's what I see when I see you.
And uh,
thanks for doing that for me and for everyone else and
okay,
obviously thanks to everyone else out there in uniform that is defending our
flag and our country to those that are serving to those that have served.
Thanks to all of you out there.
Thanks to the police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT,
dispatchers,
correctional officers,
border patrol,
secret service,
first time mentioned for the secret service and all the other first responders.
Thanks for keeping us safe here at home and for everyone else out there,
remember that.
Okay,
you might have to fight uphill.
You might have to fight against a hardened enemy that has more guns and more
people than you.
And even in those situations,
remember the path of Ron Shirt and the of special forces,
Oda?
Three,
three,
six.
Remember
to stand by your brothers,
okay.
Remember to pick up that weapon.
Remember to put one foot in front of the other and remember to keep getting
after it.
Okay.
And until next time,
this is Ron [inaudible] and echo and Jocko
out.